foreign
hey everybody it's Friday yep finally
here we go I got a real drink instead of
just that Twisted Tea stuff
which is fine but you know what I mean
the sweet tea with vodka yeah made that
tea today uh-huh
brewed that [__] long too it's good yeah
why does two cups of sugar per gallon
yeah that's real [__] redneck [__]
sweet tea there's no lemon in it yeah I
noticed not real lemony
doesn't really need it
crafter says uh thank you very much
grandthers for the gas money he was
asking the question how you like the job
so far it's all right I've had worse
jobs I honestly
um it's just this far it's a long drive
yeah I think that's kind of like the
major issue is that like the commute and
today was kind of a real cluster park
because I was like oh it's Friday and
then I hadn't even left Daytona and
there was like a um well it wasn't even
a wreck it was a car on fire and
um I didn't know that until I got up
there but we as everyone was just
sitting on us 92 and I was like what the
[__] is going on it's like I you know I
couldn't right I couldn't see what was
going on because everybody was just
stopped and I was like Jesus Christ is
it is it a wreck is it work what is it
and then finally I get up there and
there's like a burned out car on the
side of like smoldering car on the side
of the road and like the cops are just
standing around going whatever so I was
like so everybody stopped to gawk at a
burn car could you even see the body
I don't even know if somebody just set
it on fire or I mean there's it must
have happened a long time ago because
that's all that was left was like two
cop cars it's like there was no
ambulance or nothing yeah so it's like I
don't know if somebody just like
stole the car and then just left it and
set it on fire I don't know but it
didn't look like there had been a body
in it or a wrecked or anything like that
but it didn't smell I didn't smell pork
or anything
I'm just saying that's you know usually
when the body's burning it's just like
burning hair
I've smelled them before it's like oh
well I was just being I was just being
funny
but yeah so it's like I was just kind of
like
I don't know it's funny because the
first thing I thought was that I just
sat here on 92 not moving for 15 minutes
and then I get up there and it's like a
burn car that everybody just like
stopped to look at and I was like
yep that's Daytona never change never
changed okay looks like people piling in
we got
um looks like a lot of the regulars are
there
it is another Friday
we were ushering you out of the work
week and into the weekend
okay we're taking you to the Stars we're
taking you to to see the UFOs Bigfoot
all the damn serial killers wherever
they're hiding paranormal hopefully not
in here we're talking about we'll we can
talk about
we've taken you to to to the movies I'm
taking you to to Jenny's taking you to
where the books are written
and uh
we're just getting ready to uh chill out
for the coming weekend need some music
in the background that'd be nice some
[__] Space Music whenever I do the
intro and then um like I have time to
like look for that show
I don't know how to do that you guys can
put on your music in your house and
we're gonna we're gonna talk you all to
sleep
or something yeah I was gonna say it's a
little early a little bit a little bit
early because it's only 7 30. well
depending on where some people are
getting ready to go to the club
some people are in their commute
I mean I was gonna what was I gonna say
some people are already in bed
what was I gonna say you were you said
something and it reminded me of
something and I was like oh I gotta I
gotta say something and then you kept
talking and I forgot
Louis looks like Louie's there yeah
Louie's in there yeah guess what bro got
package arrived today yeah should we do
like a little thing okay yeah we just
got this today because I look I just got
home like half an hour ago this is
awesome so Hernandez trivia
it's not technically unboxing because I
already opened it yeah but we know what
it is we know what it is but yeah look
what he said great selections haven't
got either one of them we got
but
[Music]
um I'll tell you what tell you what uh
Louis in the guns in the gun scene on
guntube
there's a custom cult Commando called
the Gordon carbine that has inspired a
lot of fake builds based on that guy's
coal carbine in that in that movie and
I've seen stills of it and I've seen
guys who have faked that M4 carbine it's
a type of M4 I think
um but uh now I have some context of why
everybody wants that damn gun well I'll
see it I like the the damn Blood Diamond
xm177 I got a reproduction of it if you
guys see that one okay now the next one
is and then the next one is
Highlander Highlander is that that's the
Highlander series or is it the first one
I'm not sure is there one movie in there
or two can you see no I can't see that
okay but yeah it's nice it's like it's a
steel book okay I'll understand that's a
really uh look at that cover yeah that's
awesome I remember seeing that one when
I was a kid I loved it yeah it was like
this is really good I haven't seen it in
a long time I haven't seen a long time
they had the what was his name the the
gherkin no what was his name
gherkin is a damn [__] pickle yeah it
is the kurgan that's what it was he's
fighting the kurgan this is a pickle
monster because my name's candy because
of course you are I remember that thank
you Ian thanks alcohol money yeah we
need some of that we need some of that
yeah it's like I've gramper says what
does Tom do all day now that you're away
I don't know I went riding today
cut
um
oh I went to Momiji
did you really like the Momiji you suck
I said [__] it man I'm gonna get some
[__] Sushi it's just up a street you
sucked yeah I went there for lunch
that sounds good yeah see now he made me
rat on myself but uh I'll uh I'll just
watch movies or you aren't gonna tell me
yeah yeah uh because I was just thinking
about that the other day that we hadn't
been and I was like man I missed that
place you should see it she comes home
she I was cooking I uh making it getting
us some sandwiches ready she came she
she came home late
uh I was checking that this was a car
fire yeah I was checking the messages to
see if something went wrong with the car
but it seemed all right she comes in man
she looked tired as [__] I was like so I
guess we're not going out tonight no
well I said Memento is tonight yeah but
you you won't be able to make it I can
just tell you didn't get any sleep yeah
I've been up since four we're good we'll
go to we'll go tomorrow to um mannequins
or something
but uh I mean I feel bad because we
missed the last couple messages but it's
like it's just hard to get to so she
comes up here to get ready for the show
and I was already kind of ready I come
up here man and [__] see her she's
all dolled up you know yeah I had to get
ready really quick because I was running
late and I really hadn't seen her budget
cut in a couple days you know she's
running around in this little [__]
short Wednesday Adams looking dressed
and fall bear-legged and everything I
was getting ready to throw down man she
had to fight me off it's like don't mess
up my makeup yeah it's like I'm not
doing it over again
I've tried to reason with her it didn't
work it didn't work because I know how
you breathe in
I never listened to what you say because
it doesn't mean [__]
all I know is how you add like he'll say
all kind of [__] but it doesn't it
doesn't matter it doesn't man it doesn't
mean anything I'm trapped in my own
personal health
are you really
no you're not what are you even talking
about oh
man I'm just trying to get laid that's
all well I was just you know I was like
looking cute man look I just got home I
know I was cranky because I was in the
car for like an hour and a half picture
of this I'm [__] post can I talk okay
um I was cranky because I was in the car
for like a [__] hour and a half and I
thought I was never gonna get home
because that stupid wreck I was like
stuck in Daytona and I was just like
Jesus Christ it was getting dark and I
can't and my night vision's bad so I
don't really like to drive after dark if
you guys could see her from this angle
can I please talk about something else
Jesus Christ and then like I'm trying
and then like we're sitting here like
before the show starts and I'm trying to
like tell him something about like money
and stuff and he's he keeps doing it I'm
like I'm just I'm trying to talk to you
I'm trying and he's not listening
he's not listening
and I'm on Trend too I'm [__] about
30 days into Trend cycle but
it's got a grip on me I mean it's just
very it's very frustrating that it's
like I just feel like I can't like I had
to come home and it's like I had to get
ready for the show it's like at a stuff
a sandwich in my face real quick and
then you know and I had to like change
clothes I had to like fix my makeup I
had to like put the wig on I had to like
I had to go to the bathroom I didn't
like to you know it was like millions of
things I had to do and he's just like in
here like trying to climb on me and I'm
just like look she's not appreciate she
did not appreciate I was like please can
I appreciate my love well because it's
always like at times when I'm trying to
do something else that's when it's the
best that's when it's the best well
that's why because I'm getting like
really annoyed because I'm like look I
got [__] to do it's like
it's just when it's just that
spontaneous thing it's just seeing you
do your thing you know what I mean and
I'm just like going oh yeah it's like
it's like a it's like a it's like a big
mouth bass sitting at the bottom of the
pond and The Lure goes by you know what
I mean they can't just can't resist it
you just look at you're looking
fantastic and and uh just all the stars
were aligning and uh you know
for me you know you're like get the [__]
out of here
there's gonna be a show all right
that's gonna be a show
I just I don't know I just feel like
that's all you ever talk about and it's
like I'm trying to talk to you about
other [__] that's all I talk about yeah
that's just all I talk about okay and
it's like I can't no that's not true
like I'm just trying to talk to you
about serious [__] and you're just like
over here like
Pawn at me and everything and I'm just
like um are you listening what I'm
saying yeah
what's going it doesn't seem like it
does listen it doesn't seem like it
uh slasher friend said one of these days
you should watch them review class of
1999.
yeah okay I remember it uh Tom's and
glorious bastards says Tom you need to
make Jenny a special Valentine's dinner
he makes he makes special food all the
time yeah every day is a special day
so I don't know it sucks because
Valentine's Day is on a Tuesday so it's
like so obviously I'm gonna be working
all day so it's like we're probably not
gonna do anything we just blows but you
know whatever
you'll be back so late
yeah I won't be back till six might be
able to do momiji's
yeah I don't think we've never eaten
dinner there have we I think we could
always do some Street lunch I mean well
the thing about it though is that every
restaurant was always slammed like on
Valentine's a lot of them have you have
to um get a reservation yeah we'll see
might be able to do that
maybe I don't know you have to check and
some of them have what a lot of
restaurants do too because you know when
I used to work and I used to do all the
um the ads for all the restaurants and
stuff they um they do like what do they
call it like a prefix menu or whatever
like they you know they only have so
many things
I can look to see if I can make a
reservation for that
now like I said I don't know how my
expense it is gonna be it's gonna be
expensive well that's what I'm saying so
it's like maybe we should not bother
I mean you already ate at movies today
without wings though
we're at work I couldn't bring you with
me you were at work I ate it I ate a I
had a tuna salad sandwich yeah sweetest
salad out of a pouch no
I was [__] you over man I know I was
cheating on you with Momiji it's
cheating on me with food yeah like he's
good I'm getting good food yeah
well I was going I was sitting there I
was going I was going man I didn't want
to cook you know yeah I didn't want to
cook and uh I said I haven't been up to
I haven't had it so I want some sushi
well no no what I really wanted was that
I really wanted
um Chinese buffet
yeah and I was like
man once you add up the price of koi
want and the fuel and everything I could
just go to emiji's for that probably
it's much closer yeah it'd probably be
cheaper so I went to momiji's
there's our local sushi restaurant it's
good real good it is really good we got
that lunch special with the three rolls
yeah and then you know what I did I
spent the extra five dollars and got the
damn ice cream
two big scoops of green tea ice cream
with chocolate syrup on it yeah with uh
what do you think you got all these [__]
yeah I'm just gonna I was looking at it
tonight and then it had whipped cream
and I was looking at the price they
wanted like five dollars that's kind of
steep for a scoop of ice cream it was
two big ones
two big scoops of ice cream and a side
in a bowl that was standing up on an
angle neat it came at me like a TV set I
was like
it's the green tea ice cream yeah I was
like watching
on television
it came at me like it's here
yeah
I checked it out for you I did a Recon
okay thanks that's how you're gonna they
had another that's like your place they
had another uh um ice cream that was
more expensive what kind of like I don't
know it was it was a secret no it had a
funny name I'd never heard of it I can't
remember and it looked like the
photograph next to it looked like it had
a dragon fruit next to it or something
oh okay so maybe it was reddish fruit
with green and [__] I've never had green
and [__] yeah it looked good but I
didn't I couldn't didn't recognize it it
was something foreign
well foreign ice cream yeah yeah for an
ice cream yeah
granther says Graham is getting a
vasectomy next week [__] before the
urologist said I have to flush my vas
deferens 20 to 25 times to get my seed
fully cleaned out question should I
burden my wife or just shoot ropes to
porn
unless you think you're gonna get some
kind of cancer or something
Ian England says uh I wanted to try uh
Tom my opponent to try Trend so [__]
bad everybody says the [__] Trent is the
[__] but the first one really [__] you
up that first cycle I was crazy on that
first cycle I was barely holding on you
were yeah
um you were all over the place man I was
having emotional problems man oh
um Jenny got me through it and so did
Sophie Sophie got me through it too but
can I have start having emotional
problems and [__] and [__] and tell
soap you know yeah I'm doing this I'm
doing that and I don't know if I should
tell Jan he goes no no you can tell her
that because I didn't want to look weak
you know what I mean that's dumb so I
had to check with somebody else you know
you have to be on Trend to understand it
it's not no but I've told you it's not
normal psychology because your
progesterone is [__] going crazy I
told you that's what I'm like all the
time so it's like I didn't really
understand like why I had to check well
her I had to check whether I had a check
with a buddy first you know what I mean
somebody I could be vulnerable with you
know what I mean because I didn't want
to look weak in front of you you know
she's no no it's all right you know and
then I then I go whatever problem I was
I'm gonna tell you I don't remember
everything though now
because you know what I mean it was
mostly emotion it wasn't a lot of fact
yeah you know yeah I was imagining
things yeah you guys like real paranoid
yeah I was imagining stuff it wasn't it
wasn't I wasn't
getting upset over anything that was
real
I thought people were talking about me
um I thought Jenny was uh cheating on me
but I knew I was hallucinating that yeah
and it's because I'm like who'd you
think I was shooting yeah I never leave
the house it was
[Laughter]
see I I've done all my research who is
it that asked that I don't have my
glasses on and Ian yeah
Ian you know you you listen to all the
trend stories you can go and look at
[__] more plates more dates old
[__] Derek he's got a whole [__] a
whole section of videos of people that's
mailed in their Trend stories to him
and that's the common theme they said
you better watch it man that'll [__] up
your relationships but there's mostly
young guys you know
that that have problems so I knew that I
would probably end up start thinking
like that
it took a while but I started to but I
recognized it you know as long as you're
aware of what it does
you're not fooled by it you know but you
still feel it but it's it's [__]
though
it's it's like a it's not a Justified
emotion
it's just weird suspicions get
suspicious I think people are talking
about you
uh you feel like Superman
but then you also feel inadequate at the
same time
um which that's weird you feel because
you feel like pregnant Superman
pregnancy pregnant Superman yeah what if
there's porn of that yes I just answered
it's weird but
um
on this second cycle
and I'm doing more of it
I'm doing 50 milligrams a day
um I've just built up a tolerance to it
I guess it I'm um
I'm emotional but it's not negative
yeah you don't seem to be acting all
that weird
not like before but the thing about it
was that before
you you weren't telling me a lot of
stuff so I didn't really know what was
going on until later on I was getting
paranoid that's what I mean yeah like I
didn't so I didn't notice much of a
difference until later when you actually
started talking about it because you
didn't tell me anything but I knew it
was my imagination right you know what I
mean
yeah like there's no way to describe it
but see that's the thing like I told you
I mean I kind of feel like that all the
time and have ever since I can remember
but I also don't tell anybody about it
because why would I all right
well I don't want to burden anybody else
with all my emotional problems
you know what's funny is you're having
all that you on tread you're having all
these weird emotional
issues but there's no issue
there there you know what I mean right
there's nothing causing it and that's
the thing that's really [__] with you
you know
you know like I feel this way but
there's no reason for me to feel this
way it's just emotion yeah
well I have that well I have that like
about various like anxieties and things
like that like I'll feel anxiety about
something then then like the other half
of my brain is being like why are you
anxious about that either a you can't do
anything about it or it's probably not
as bad as you think but but it doesn't
matter I still feel like that anyway and
it's like [__] me up you know what I
mean so that's me all the time see Ian
if you do tests
test is all about confidence and uh
uh positive kind of energy and um
you know test just feels normal to a guy
feels good
tread
it's a natural loan based molecule
it's kind of like test
but it's like it's evil it's a little
bit like a nadralone too but it's kind
of like it's evil twin and it just
causes your body to react by putting out
a bunch of [__] progesterone which
guys don't have a lot of progesterone
normally
so you just start becoming like a woman
I guess
you just
not fun is it no I told you no but uh it
was just that first one
um just that first cycle the second
cycle it didn't seem to affect me the
same way
because your system learns once it comes
in contact with this stuff
it'll figure out how to process it and
kind of normalize in your system
so I think what's happened is is that it
it now recognizes it for what it is and
it goes oh yeah I've seen this before it
just does this this is what it's for and
it puts it in the receptor and then
fires off some signals uh just for
muscle growth and other stuff and
um that makes you very lean it starts
burning a lot of [__] fat off you I
mean you just [__] a sweat constantly
and wake up sweats at night and just
grease greasy sweats you just lose a lot
of fat
um
but it feels a lot better than it did
although I don't approve of trend
s The Last Resort
it's very cost effective but I don't
think it's too good for you
Zach says uh same with me Jenny I hate
it yeah I do too but who said that Zach
okay
it's hard to explain to somebody that
doesn't feel like that but
I don't know I think about this a lot
because I'm just kind of like well I
hate being like that but if I
try to be another way like I wouldn't be
me anymore and I don't think I would
like that either so it's like I can't
really win you know what I mean
I don't know I don't know what it is I
don't know what my problem is I probably
need therapy but I can't afford it so
[__] it Terry says uh Jenny there's a
movie on freebie written by Nick Cave
called The Proposition uh it's a western
type Stars Guy Pierce I've seen it it's
actually really really really good
um Nick Cave has done I think that's the
only one he's written the screenplay for
if I remember correctly but he's scored
some films though too like he's done
some westerns I think he scored
um
that other God damn it what was the name
of that other Western the assassination
of Jesse James by the coward Robert Ford
I think he scored that movie and um
there was a couple other ones too it's
like him and um [__] that dude that's
that other dude that's in the The Bad
Seeds whose name I can't remember
something uh is that lane or e in
England Ian Ian okay
that's right because that would be a
capital l would be
yeah that's a that's an alternate
spelling of Ian yeah I've never seen a
spell yeah
well there's two spellings some people
spell it i a n and some people spell it
I a i n yeah
Trey says hey guys I'm at work so I
can't stay be cool everyone oh that's a
shame but you know gotta make that money
gotta make that money
just like I gotta do
Michael says no need to work I offered
to pay for a room what does that mean
what I don't have to work anymore
awesome
someone's just gonna pay me to stay home
I would like that
but uh but yeah I mean
I got a lot of I got a lot of freelance
work I gotta do this week too so with
this weekend
but that's more money so you know
but like I said I'm kind of like
I'm gonna have to buy a new car at some
point because the car I got is like
really old and I'm really like scared
that um if you keep this job yeah you
may not
yeah we'll see how it goes like I said I
I like it it's just it's very far
you know your other things might come
your way you just have to see yeah I'm
keeping I'm keeping options open always
yeah
Zach says he also did the music for the
Marilyn Monroe movie
really oh I'd forgotten all about that
and I was convinced it was Trent rezner
and the other guy who Fincher always
works with
well [__] now I'm really gonna have to
watch that I know I kept saying I was
gonna see it and I just never got around
to seeing it you know what I'm saying
somebody asked if we were going to
review Megan
um I've been wanting to see that because
there's like so much Buzz about it but I
guess we'll have to wait for it to come
on streaming because we never go to the
damn movie theaters anymore oh yeah well
I killed my uh EMC yeah I did too
because like I couldn't afford it
anymore because we never went never went
anyway so you know it's so far you would
think there'd be one out here
I don't I think there's a movie theater
closer but I don't think it's an AMC
I mean there wasn't when I checked you
would think there'd be one in Mount Dora
but I don't know if there is I mean I
didn't think so yeah Zach said also I
think a show about Marilyn Monroe would
be awesome yeah I did write that down or
just right well yeah just kind of like
there's a Kennedy connection there
somebody asked us to do a show about the
JFK assassination too yeah that's a big
subject though that's what I was gonna
say it's like maybe and and go ahead I
was going to say that maybe
um now that I won't have as much time to
like do researches for the show so I've
been trying to like pick some stuff for
the polls it's like easier you know what
I mean that's like not like super super
complicated because I won't have time to
like get into it as much they were gonna
do they tried to declassify that stuff
and I think they reclassified it but
recently but uh I believe it basically
leaked that yeah they they killed him
CIA had something to do with it which I
probably
probably means that that book that I
read about it
it's called Mafia Kingpin I think was
called Mafia Kingpin I think was the
name of the book
that laid out a real compelling case I
read it a long time ago I guess that was
uh
90s
there was a an Italian mobster in New
Orleans his name was Carlos Marcellus
and he was friends with Edwin Edwards
who was a local politician who ended up
being the governor
he was friends with him because he was
an inmate trustee that works at the
mansion
and that's at the governor's mansion and
that's how he met Edwards before Edwards
was the governor
Marcellus got out of prison was still
friends with
um Edwin Edwards and they ran some
rackets together with slot machines
getting slot machines into local bars
they were divided the money
and uh so Marcellus and the the guy that
ended up being the governor of New
Orleans of of uh Louisiana
they were buddies they ran together for
a long long time
Marcellus met this other dude eventually
who was an ex-cia agent he was gay guy
that had alopecia he said he was very
bizarre to look at because he always
wore a wig and he had his eyebrows
painted on
and that guy
an ex-cia guy was running this thing
called the free Cuba movement
working with Cuban Rebels
and they were trying to retake Cuba and
the mob was involved and a lot of
American politicians were involved in
retaking Cuba and the Kennedys
did the Bay of Pigs thing where they
betrayed
those Cuban Rebels that the CIA was
funded
Marcellus was involved in that
well Bobby Kennedy ended up being uh who
was the ended up being the uh the uh
what was it the head [__] district
attorney what do they call that guy
in charge of the [__]
the Federal
[__] what's that guy's name what's the
name of that anyway they were going to
Stamp Out The Mob the Kennedys were
and marcelos who was part of the Italian
mob got pissed off at that and he hooked
up with that CIA guy
and then they found this other guy named
Lee Harvey Oswald who was in that free
Cuba movement and to avenge the free
Cuba movement they uh planned that
assassination
but he wasn't alone there were other
ones that whole that according to that
book there was about three Shooters and
the other two got away
so when they uh
when they caught Oswald he said I'm a
patsy
he was probably telling the truth I
think he shout and he I think he shot
at least one of his rounds probably hit
the president
but he wasn't the only one they gave him
up on purpose he was going to be the
Patsy then a few days later they
silenced him they sent another another
gangster named Jack Ruby who was
connected in with Marcellus and all that
guys and they killed him to silence him
and uh then Ruby died in prison and died
of cancer in prison and he said that he
got injected with cancer while he was in
prison
and it was a suicide mission because
he'd fallen into debt he owned a strip
club he'd fallen into the debt to the
Mob they were going to kill him
and they they gave they made him a deal
they said look if you do if you kill
that Jack Ruby guy we know you liked the
president for you killed Jack Ruby you
Avenged the president's death
will um
we won't kill you you can go to prison
and you're you're surviving family
members we won't kill them
so that's why he did it that's why Ruby
did it
so yeah man um and I think that's what
they tried to declassify because uh I
kept hearing little details about that
case I think even Oliver Stones had
found some of this stuff out so I think
that book was correct
about
marcelo's the xcia contractor guy who
was doing the free Cuba thing
and the Kennedys that had to do with
that and trying to Stamp Out The Mob
Kennedy's trying to Stamp Out My what
was what's the name of the big district
attorney on the federal level what are
they called
what's that what's Bobby Kennedy became
uh
the attorney general attorney general
Michael said did you guys ever gonna
make him attorney general did you guys
ever review heat we did didn't we I
thought we did yeah I'm pretty sure we
did I think it wasn't too long ago
either
it's a decent
I still want to do Casino as well
because I remember really really liking
that and I haven't seen that in a really
long time
um Toms and glorious bastards said I saw
the new cage western flick oh the one
with Nicholas Cage in it it's not that
bad cage killing Banditos caging the
[__] out
man he's like he's in every movie now
he must be like
how much money does he need
it's like he's in every single movie it
seems like it seems like every time I
open a new streaming service it's like
well there's a new Nicholas Cage movie
how does he have time I don't really
know
I don't really know
uh let's see okay here's all the stuff
about the JFK
yeah casino is good yeah I think I saw
it in the theater and I remember really
really liking it a lot and I've been
wanting to like re-watch it
um
I was laughing because when you
mentioned the strip club I was thinking
that the strip club Jack Ruby strip club
yeah it reminded me that on my drive to
work I passed the famous strip club
called Soft Tails okay and their sign
and it's funny because I remember
passing it a long time because it's been
there forever
um I remember passing it a long time ago
and their sign still says the same thing
which is 23 pretty girls and one ugly
one
and it's like I always remembered that
and I was like I passed it the other day
and I was like that [__] side still
says that after all these years where is
that Daytona Delta or DeLand actually
it's in DeLand yeah but must be a biker
it's like a biker strip club yeah it's
better to go check that out it's been
there as long as I can remember they're
probably all ugly in there aren't they I
don't how would I know I've never been
there I have to go check that out it's
just while you're at work I'm gonna go
check that out man he's gonna go eat
sushi he's gonna go look at strippers
yeah they're gonna live it up man
must be nice
while I'm out slaving away for the money
I'm not gonna do it I don't care if you
do nothing whatever just whatever
but I just I thought it was funny
because I remember that place like
having that sign from a long time ago
and I just laughed because it still has
it
I mean you know it's a funny line so I
guess they're like why change it
[Laughter]
why change it
what's up Pokey she came up to see if
she I thought she was mad at me because
I'm not home as much anymore
if you ever want to have a good time at
a strip club you got to take Jen with
you every time [__] me and Jen went
to strip club together we had a [__]
great time [__] strippers love her
strippers love me yeah
well I told you before any strippers
um because we know some yeah strippers
like women to come to the strip clubs
because they're sick of like gross ass
men being in the strip clubs all the
time and having to deal with that every
year yeah they went up there to [__]
complain to her right so it's like yeah
so when there's a woman there they're
like oh thank God Kaylee was with us who
was our little lesbian kitty cat and
that's a little bit that's the girl that
died of cancer for a little thing and
look and I'm trying to hook her up with
this stripper and this other she's like
one of the top strippers there and she's
like oh no I'm not into girls oh no no
you take this and take this one and I'm
[__] pushing pushing it just [__]
funny
and [__] bad I don't know how he made
it home that night
yeah half that down bars half of the
[__] hat it was a big battle of the
of the bartenders event
and half of our friends ended up [__]
sleeping in the parking lot they slept
in their cars in the parking lot it was
like the [__] it was a good thing they
couldn't make it back
and [__] um our friend Mark
who's he's a that [__] he
he's an ancient drunk and he he couldn't
make it back if Mark couldn't make it
back that's the yeah you know is there
was a lot of alcohol he's older than us
yeah and he's got a girlfriend named
Laura and there but two of the tall
skinny people and uh a good looking
couple
and they slept in the car yeah I don't
think they're together anymore no yeah
no they were together a long time but
yeah she replaced him with a bodybuilder
they're still talking I have a
bodybuilder half her age
yeah I don't remember how old she is
about 50. no she's younger than me isn't
she she's older than Aleta
by about a year or so and the latest
um 40
7.
46. okay see I thought Laura was younger
than me no and I'm Laura's a little bit
older than
Laura's Laura's a little bit older than
than Alexa
and late is a little bit younger than
you
or about the same age late I think a
lady just turned 50.
or near there
what's funny is that all these people
were talking about if you were to see
them
you would never know that they were 50.
you know more like really well preserved
late 30s and 40s
I don't know why it's just
I told you because we stay out of the
Sun
a vanity has a lot to do with it they
keep up with their appearances uh
Mark and Laura weren't doing any kind of
performance drugs or hormones or
anything it was just well Laura if she's
like one of those caloric restriction
[__] and then she does uh
aerobics I think yeah she's just real
thin
um probably weighs 90 something pounds
um and
Mark didn't weigh much more than that is
he's just skinny bones
which I think he's too skinny man
especially at his age
they might have been are they
vegetarians yeah no no
well I think she is I don't think he is
maybe maybe
because I thought one of them I thought
at least one of them was a vegetarian
because didn't we didn't they come to
that party that we had and yeah maybe
well I know there was a couple of
vegetarians there that we because I know
we have vegetarian stuff a late is a
vegetarian now I think
I tried it for a while but yeah it's not
worth it I like meat too much yeah yeah
it's not really a good diet
well the thing about it is that
it's easier nowadays like I feel like
when I tried to do it you didn't have
all these options like you have nowadays
like now it's much easier to be a
vegetarian but you know and they even
have meat substitutes that are pretty
good that are pretty good yeah I've seen
some of them yeah they don't I mean they
don't taste exactly like meat but
they're okay I mean they're possible I
even we tried one of those impossible
Whoppers didn't we like at Burger yeah
it wasn't bad yeah it was all right I
don't know what the what the Patty
tasted like by itself like you don't
know what's in it but on the bun with
all the condiments and stuff it tasted
pretty it tasted there's supposed to be
a bunch of things that equate to
estrogens in there that are not really
good for men
uh make you fat
it's just
a vegetarian diet's a lot better than a
vegan diet vegan's really bad
um most people don't have the genetics
for that
I mean the best vegans in the world
would be North Koreans and they're tiny
and frail
and they get smaller every generation
you're not really vegan is not that's a
religious Choice it doesn't have
anything to do with reality
um
again human beings they're omnivores
they're just a
scavenger they'll they ate whatever they
found uh you have to have some protein
in there
and plant protein is not quite the same
as animal protein and the proof is in
the pudding you just look at
bodybuilders uh they've had guys that
have tried to
do the vegan diet
and go on steroids and compete with guys
who are eating mostly meat and they
they've always failed you just protein
synthesis happens
ideally eating meat
and to get it from vegetables
the you have to eat so much so much the
caloric intake is so much that you're
going to get fat more than you're gonna
build even under the influence of
steroids you're going to get fat
or you'll still kind of waste away you
underneath under the work under the
stress of work
the best diet
in terms of protein quality it's been
proven
back in the 80s
70s and 80s
there were there were um bodybuilders
[__] ifbb Pro Olympia one of them was
ended up in Olympia
just a sheer leanness to health the size
and and being on steroids at that level
is [__] totally unhealthy they're
they're abusing it they're taking so
much he was eat he was a pescetarian
fish
fish is the best protein well that's why
they tell you like Mediterranean diet is
probably like the best kind because they
eat a lot of fish yeah
so because fish is probably like the
best me it's the leanest it's lean it's
it's easy to digest there's something
about the the body the the little
mitochondria and then the and the little
cellular nuclei that you have in your
body can somehow even can Pro can
process that and turn it into lean
muscle mass very easily
when you start when you have mix good
genes with steroids and that diet those
dudes [__] just come out fantastic
just
superhuman the problem with fish diet or
pescetarianism
is the cost it's expensive
that's the problem
I mean beef is cheaper
chicken's much cheaper
but when you're doing what those guys
were doing you have to eat a lot of it a
lot you know they were eating shellfish
and [__] octopus and shrimp and
fish of all different kinds that shit's
[__] good for you real good
and I yeah and I feel like I can eat
more fish yeah than I can other kinds of
meat without like feeling ill you know
what I mean I can sit down I mean
depending on how it's cooked like if
it's fried then I can only eat one Patty
and then I'm gonna barf but like I can
eat a mountain of boiled shrimp yeah I
can just eat boiled shrimp all day long
I could probably eat my own weight in
that [__] yeah it's like and I don't
feel sick or full or anything like that
I think I could eat probably five pounds
of boiled shrimp
probably yeah
and you just be oh
no maybe not five pounds maybe more like
four I don't know you probably couldn't
find them
John Smith said uh vegetarian for 15
years meat substitutes have come uh come
on Leaps and Bounds yeah they're a lot
better because I remember like trying to
do it like back in like the late 80s or
like early 90s and there wasn't really a
lot of options you know what I mean that
weren't terrible like now it's super
easy like to find something it's a mix
they said the vegan cheese is always
awful yeah they can't get cheese right
can they like like I said I've seen some
meat I've had some meat substitutes that
are actually pretty good they're not
exactly like meat but they're you know
meat adjacent like they're close enough
but yeah the cheese is just always
there's something weird about the cheese
and I don't know why they can't get it
veganism is an abomination
and I say that Sophie was a was a vegan
and I'm glad that she's become more of a
she'll eat tuna now and she'll eat a
little bit of meat
because
that's just you're that's not a diet
that's sustainable for health now
vegetarianism
with if you throw in a little bit of
dairy or you know then yeah that's a lot
better what's better to be
pescetarianism which is you know fish
and vegetables and you know hell yeah
yeah I feel like even if you're just
mostly vegetarian but just eat fish like
as you're eating protein then that's
probably the biggest ideal situation
yeah and um which I can probably do that
although I don't know I would miss beef
and I would miss turkey now the thing is
is that vegetarians can get
they're not so strict so they can get
decent protein yes because I think that
I think a vegetarian will uh will eat
whey protein and I think a vegetarian
will will eat
Dairy yeah and you know it's only vegans
that don't eat yeah you dare so you know
you want to have some cottage cheese you
know you want to have uh some cheese you
want to have some butter
yeah Butter's good for you people think
oh Butter's not good better it's bad for
you now that was a a black propaganda
campaign to sell margarine okay
um
[__] butter is better for you than
vegetable oil and that's all that
margarine is Camp guy said eggs yeah I
love eggs eggs on eggs you could because
um yeah they're one of the most
nutritionally perfect food yeah
there are low calorie high protein you
know low fat it's like you know there's
a lot of cholesterol in them but that's
it's not as big a deal as you think the
problem with the vegetarian diet they've
got a lot of fake vegetarian
bodybuilders out there they got fake
vegan bodybuilders
um but the problem with with uh
vegetarianism is that
you're going to be restricted to being
either very thin or skinny fat it's it's
you're not going to be able to get
really muscular on that it's just
because to get the amount of protein you
need to synthesize and that that protein
into muscle is going to put your caloric
intake very high
the reason why Meat and Fish are so good
is because it's a very concentrated
source of low calorie protein
a lot of protein in it no calories in it
all right so that's the difference
a lot of that vegetarian protein has a
lot of calories and a lot of fat in it
like peanut butter a lot of fat you know
well I was gonna say I feel like nuts
are a good source but you of protein but
you can't eat can you well now it
depends on now peanuts are to have a
higher fat content than like some other
kind of nuts and I think cashews are the
highest even though because they're the
most delicious so obviously but I think
almonds are better because it's like
there's fat but there's not as much fat
as like peanuts and cashews have a
bodybuilder though needs several pounds
of protein a day and to get to several
pounds of protein from peanuts is not
not
yeah I'm talking about the extremes
levels though I'm saying the difference
is the difference is is that you're
going to be restricted to a normal type
looking physique if you're kind of a
lightweight physique if you're a
vegetarian
Zach said I always wonder if your
ancestry determines things you like and
don't like yeah like food probably to an
extent
um and I think too it has to do with
like what you were exposed to as a child
also also what you can metabolize
white people and and African people and
Hispanics can't metabolize rice at the
same
the same way Asian people can
um they produce a lot more insulin and
they have the they have the genes they
were because they've been living in
whole empires of rice for thousands of
years anybody that couldn't handle rice
is long weeded out of gene pool
all right now you do have some people
who are non-asian that have
proper genes to make good use of rice
but nah man we're mostly about wheat
and corn things like that
yeah because that's kind of what we've
that's what we it's our ancestors we're
eating well yeah and like I said there's
kind of like it's it's becoming more
diffuse nowadays as people kind of like
move around more than they used to but
you know there's that whole thing too
about how you know Europeans could like
digest milk and like other cultures
couldn't because because of Agriculture
and like raising cows and children yeah
you can give lactose tolerance to people
but you have to start them off small it
takes a time I think you know like small
amounts of it but I think
so I'm not sure if if lactose tolerance
in in Western people I don't know if
it's genetic or if it's just because
they raised it as children with it's
probably genetic though isn't it because
I think I mean it might be it might be a
little bit of both to be and that's just
like most things are
man I don't know what I would do if I
was lactose intolerant and I know a lot
of people are but it's like I
I would hate to like not be able to have
cheese yeah because man cheese is the
best
[__] love cheese
but yeah I would be sad if I could well
I would I would be sad if I could need a
lot of things because I like pretty much
everything obviously in the in the
modern world now because you have mass
transit and good supply lines and
knowledge in the internet
everybody has opportunities of eating
everybody else's food so now you're
coming in contact with foods that have
never been into your corner of the
universe you know right
but it doesn't mean you can get away
with eating them in large amounts white
people eating lots of rice regularly
you're gonna get fat yes I just said
that Tom's right about rice that makes
me faster
and you're well it's because your
insulin response man
[__] uh blood sugar starts coming in
you start producing [__] insulin like
crazy and when you got a lot of insulin
in your bloodstream one of the things
that it does is that you can't burn fat
when you have real high insulin content
and then part of your body's going man
we can't [__] break down all this
sugar store it
so it starts storing it as fat because
you just stick it in their ass for later
or somewhere the sugar sugar you know
sugars are actually poisons in a way you
know the body has a reaction kind of a
negative reaction to them
um
but for a lot of caucasians
rice
too much of it kind of a strong insulin
response to it but you won't but what's
funny is that we could eat potatoes and
not get that same response
it's just rice
yeah I mean I feel like
if you eat enough potatoes you get fat
too but you know what I mean well and
especially if it's like french fries and
[__] it's not that same response but
yeah it's not as severe yeah which is
good because I [__] love potatoes
also I don't know about mesoamericans my
Mexican Brothers can tell me if uh if
they gain get fat on Rice because rice
is not native to to Central and South
America that's imported in there
those are corn people Empire is built
upon corn yeah which is nothing more
than a selectively bred big piece of
wheat
if you breed wheat to be big enough
eventually just becomes a year of corn
well it's a it's technically a different
plan it's called teosinte but it looks
like wheat to me and it does kind of I
think it might be slightly in the same
family but it's not exactly now when you
see pictures of Mayan and Mesoamerican
artwork from back in the day
1500s 1400s they're showing the right
the the corn and it's little
it's like a baby corn almost yeah it's
not big it's a little corn
so it's not that not today's Monsanto
corn that they're you know it's not well
even before Monsanto got involved there
was all kind of like just Farmers doing
like breeding for like bigger just like
everything was
that's why I was I don't know why I was
thinking about this the other day
because oh I know why because I was
watching a video about
um uh Kirk Cameron and you know how he
hung out with that crazy like
creationist dude like Ray Comfort yeah
and one of their big things was
creationism is true because the bananas
yeah yeah is perfectly like it it has it
fits perfectly in the human hands and
it's like it's got its own wrapper
really keeps it fresh and it's really
nutritious and everything I'm like you
guys know that we made those right it's
like natural bananas didn't look like
that at all engineered like they're
genetically engineered by humans yeah to
serve man yeah and the same thing with
corn yeah it's like that's not wild corn
like the original plant doesn't look
like that look there's that that was
Farmers doing that like over the years
spooky was behind the curtain that's
where she's meant Oh you sneaky little
she's gonna sleep
I came home last night and usually like
I'll see her like when I come home you
know what I mean and I was just kind of
like where's pookie it's like I haven't
seen her since I got home I was like is
she mad at me because I'm not here like
to give her Brushy all day you know what
I mean so she's like this is some
[__] and so we went all around this
[__] house going where is Pookie like
we couldn't fight her was like did she
get out somehow is she like locked in a
closet you know we couldn't find her
anywhere and then finally Tom's like he
calls him he's like I found her she was
like behind where was she she was like
downstairs between the sliding glass
door and the shades yeah she was like
tucked in there like and she was just
looking at me I had to flash and she
heard us calling and she was just like
the flashlight and everything and the
[__] is looking for me and I Saw
The Gleam of those lights a little bit
and I went down and looked and she's
looking like yeah yeah so I've been
calling you and she's like okay
I don't care I didn't want to come out
I'm mad at you
funny she does that she does that too if
she knows we're going somewhere like if
we're going out to the club or something
and usually I like to check and make
sure you know where she is like before
we leave because it's like you know I
don't want her to be like like I said
like locked in a closet or something
like that because she runs in the closet
sometimes without me looking
and so I always try to find her like
before we leave
and so she knows we're leaving because
like we're dressed up and stuff and she
will deliberately hide because I think
I think she thinks that if she hides we
won't leave
maybe either that or she's just mad and
that's how she's like lashing out what's
she doing stinky butt
her butt's not stinky anymore
it's all cleared up yes yes your little
problem all cleared up Pokey slash Sly
said that rice made him fat yeah
gonna put a lot of weight on me too I
love it though I love rice it's just
it's I'm more of a noodle girl I like
rice but it's not it's not my first
choice I'm more of a noodle and potato
person I get fat on noodles too well
yeah I know I would I don't eat them
that much but I'm just saying that if
you gave me a choice it's like here's
this delicious uh goulash or whatever
would you like it on rice noodles or
potatoes rice would always be my last
pick yeah you know
I think it was because when I was
younger like every now and then we we'd
have rice and it was always Minute Rice
yeah and we would almost always have
rice with Salisbury steak
so it's like I always like associate it
with that
I don't know why I'm talking about food
you were saying that eggs were super
food I'm gonna mention it again I gotta
get back into it and do some more
research
got the garden out in the back
it froze over but it's gonna come back
most of it's going to come back
uh there's a couple things I'm going to
lose yeah it freezes in Florida too
sometimes not that often but and I lost
one banana tree
oh it died one of them did one out of
the two yeah
and um
but it should be okay anyway uh what I
was going to say is the uh
the Housing Authority here I got
0.9 Acres
and if it if only had if it was one
aircraft shoot I could shoot out here
they shoot here anyway but yeah I hear
it all the time
the other thing is is that they won't
allow chickens
and eggs are getting to be where they're
like almost three something a dozen here
that's a lot of money for Florida
I heard they're getting to be [__]
outrageously expensive in places like
California like [__] six to eight
dollars a dozen that's ridiculous
so I had this idea they won't let us
have chickens
you could get a pretty bird cage
one that'll cover up a wall and you can
put quail in there
and uh Quail lay a lot of these little
bitty eggs
and if they don't make any noise and
they're clean Little Birds
and they're kind of pretty and evidently
you can let them out every day and
they'll Fly Away
and then they'll all come back at night
like pigeon I don't know if it's true
but I think it is true and then they lay
the eggs and everything is and as long
as you're
not killing them you know what I mean
but but you're just stealing the eggs
and you're feeding them that they'll
that they'll produce eggs forever
and you can let their population grow a
little bit
and if some of them got old you could
take them one by one and chop your heads
off and eat them
quail's pretty good
yeah I've had Quail before and it
wouldn't be like having nasty ass
chickens because I've [__] taken care
of chicken coops before man that [__]
those
stinky ass chicken coops they got
chickens running around everywhere
which you know this place isn't big
enough for that anyway
no we don't know and the chickens think
that they're [__] your friend and
they want to come in the house
and they want to get up on top all the
damn park benches or the benches that
you have out in the [__] backyard
well yeah they want everything they want
to be they want to play too yeah they
want they let us in the house man come
on you're giving feet let us in you know
so just like you guys got a nice
air-conditioned [__] in there it's like
you know we're just sleeping out here in
this stinky ass [__] cage they start
thinking they're pets no thank you yeah
I mean you can't blame them they're not
stupid
but I gotta go back look at it I think
they said if you had five of them
three or four people they made enough
eggs eventually that
three or four people could live off of
it
yeah yeah
because they they lay I think they laid
egg every other day something like that
so you get like a dozen eggs but or more
than a dozen eggs in [__] six days no
quail eggs are slightly they're more
than chicken they're smaller but you can
still use them well yeah that's what I
mean you can just make an omelette or
something yeah you just need more you
just need more of them of them you need
more of that's fine but I'd have a whole
bunch of them I probably have about 10
of them
and let them go
see if they came back
well don't pay a lot for them because
then the first day you're like yo be
free and then they'll continue well they
didn't come back I think they're cheap I
think they're cheap they got they got
all these Farm places around here
[__] I'm sure that they're like an
order we were gonna go like investigate
yeah I gotta investigate more about it
but evidently they're quiet they don't
make a lot of noise
they don't make that weird like yeah but
they're not in a screeching and [__]
crowing in the morning and you know and
calling and they uh they're pretty quiet
like pigeons you know
yeah they would just come in to sleep
and then the daytime let them out
and when they come back in you feed them
whatever they do all day
they fly around and eat and they do it
in like a little um school or a flock
and then they come back
they come back to where they've been
where they've been where you've been
feeding them I might be able to put that
cage on the on the back porch
maybe outside
and that's technically not breaking the
the the the the housing [__]
commissions rules because it's not
chickens it's it's
yeah I'm sure there were kind of people
there's not chicken yeah
yeah
it'd be like having pigeons and you're
letting them go
see I wonder if they'd be mad if you
like had pigeons
there's no rule against it
but they don't make any eggs or big
enough eggs I guess no I'm just saying
like just you know hypothetically
Mike Tyson he had all kinds of pigeons
it's like they didn't say that I
couldn't keep pet Bears either yeah
that doesn't mean they're gonna let me
or like you know a bobcat
you could keep a bear in this place you
could keep a bear they probably wouldn't
know you had it as long as well because
there's bears walking around there's
Bears yeah
just what about the thing is is hand
raised Bears don't like to go anywhere
it would just hang out on the back porch
and [__] walk up to people and ask
for food and [__]
yeah
somebody would [__] go in the
neighbor's refrigerators and stuff like
that
you'd have to have a [__] collar on
it or people would shoot it and then if
they had a collar on it somebody would
call the [__] cab control they go
who's got a [__] pet bear they'd look
for you they just wait for that bear
scare that bear
that [__] right there has got a
bear and you'd be in deep [__]
behind you and take the bear and then
they'd euthanize the bear the [__]
[__] they did they would euthanize
that bear I don't know I do not I'm not
a big fan of the way [__]
uh animal control deals with [__] they
[__] killed all a whole bunch of the
Bears at the old place that we lived
over a [__]
over a misunderstanding yeah yeah I was
upset about that yeah killed a bunch of
bears those bears were friendly
and they said well that's why we have to
kill them they're getting too friendly
with people
I'm like well it's a [__] trash
pandas man but all they do is [__]
you know they're they're big overgrown
[__] raccoon is all it is well what
makes me mad about the whole thing is
that they're like okay well all these
people want to buy these big fancy
[__] half million dollar houses
in you know kind of rural areas on the
outskirts yeah on the outskirts of the
town and then they moved to the house
like ooh look at all the foliage and all
the woods and everything and they'll oh
no animals I'm like duh this is where
they live before and then they get mad
and they're like oh my God there's Bears
going through my trash I'm like yeah the
Bears lived here before you did you
wanted to live in the [__] woods and
this is how [__] convoluted their
thinking is
they'd move out here from New York call
animal control and tell them to kill the
bear and then they want to do some [__]
like band hunting
what the [__] you just had them kill a
[__] bear and you and you don't
[__] but but but hunting is bad you
know [__] just they're just stupid
what happened before what happened
settlers they're [__] they've come
here to settle [__] like on a great
Frontier they think that they're on the
frontier and what do they do when they
settle the frontier they [__] burn
the whole [__] place down you change
it and [__] put tarmac and [__]
asphalt all over it and [__] say it's
now civilized well I'm just saying that
if you want to live in in the country or
in the country then you'd be out there
with the animals then animals also live
in the country yeah I mean I've that's
kind of part of the experience you just
kind of have to deal with when you moved
out here right so well the thing that
happened before like when we lived in
Sanford where there was the animal
control killed all those Bears it was
because I don't I can't remember exactly
what happened but like a bear
the bear was trying to get into the
refrigerator in the garage right no
what happened was
is somebody it was it was a woman from
India
she opened her garage door
and left left the garage door open
in the garage next to the car up in the
back was the garbage can
the bear walked into the garage went
down the side of the car to wear the
garbage can was and was looking into the
garbage okay we just got in here she
came out of the house opened the door
walked into the walked into the garage
and when she did that she trapped the
Bear in between
the car and the garbage can
and the bear tried to run and get out of
get out of the garage but the only way
out of the garage was through her
so it ran
up to her and grabbed her
um but I I think by the ankle
and Drug her a little bit and then drug
her out of the way and then let go and
ran away yeah it didn't like kill her or
nothing it was just kind of like hey
move gonna get out of here by and then
ran off
and then she called the she called the
cops and hysterical
and uh then they killed like [__] 12
Bears I thought it was seven but yeah it
was [__] it was a lot
that was like not our neighborhood but
it was one like um about a mile up the
road yeah all the local Bears vanished
after that happened they all [__]
died yeah nice I used to see them all
the time I had to have him come look at
me and [__] it'd be waiting we came home
in the club they had one of them sitting
out there like a man in our [__]
driveway
and I came up on him he rolled over oh
[__]
he walked away
he's like man I was all comfortable he
was big too if he were to stand up he'd
probably be eight feet tall yeah he was
a vegan big
um now
if you look at the statistics most
people who are killed by bears are
killed by black bears
but that's just because there are so
many of them
there's so many black bears they're just
[__] common
um they are they're not an aggressive
bear as far as bears go they'll run away
before they'll attack
um you can even
grab
a black bear cub in front of the mama
and walk off with it I mean she won't
attack you she wouldn't advise you but
because the [__] ammo control does it
all the time they'll grab a [__]
they'll grab they'll grab two [__]
Cubs and walk off like that and the mama
will just follow
and they'll take it to the truck they go
to the trail climb up in a truck and
she'll get in the truck with them and
she'll put the they'll put the
babies down and then leave and then just
shut the truck and they're and then
they'll relocate them
they're not very aggressive
now they do a lot of signaling stamping
the ground growling and making noises
that's because they're [__]
they very rarely comes to blows
they do a lot of warning
a lot of growling but it's all [__]
brown bear or a Grizzly there's very
little warning
if they want you they just strike
without any signal then just bite you to
death they're huge they're much bigger a
lot more aggressive
but um but there are but black bears and
all bears are complicated creatures they
have personalities and histories
they know when humans have shot
bears that they know they know that you
know some bears go hey man these these
humans are bad
and they've had black bears that just
were just hell-bent on killing people
I mean you can't blame them right now
it's a full grown it's usually
full-grown males
do it and usually ones that have been
hit by a car or
um hurt by people
um or that they've seen
other Bears get shot they're smart
they're like a dog but they have the
intelligence of a [__] of a chimp
they're you can see people interacting
videos guys interacting with them and
you can read their body language and you
can empathize with what the Bear's
feeling and they're very communicative
you know and real social
you know exactly what the bear is
feeling you know
um and they're they're pretty Advanced
you can throw a ball to them and they'll
throw the ball back and you throw them
ball back and forth they
it's bizarre you wouldn't think that
a bear would do that but no you can play
ball with a bear
pretty intelligent
they can open a car door
they can open a [__] door to a house
you
know yeah yeah they figure it out yep
I've seen them getting cars I've seen
them open refrigerators I've seen them
open I'm turning the knob and pushing
through them
and I've seen videos of people go look
at this look look he's got the phone and
and he looks in his kitchen and there's
a bear standing in laying on the ground
in front of the [__] in front of the
in front of the refrigerator and all the
food is poured on him well you guys got
in here
all the food's on him and he's eating
and he says you're in my house because I
don't know this bear I don't know this
bear
and the bear just looks man the food's
[__] great come get some of this
share with share bear is not scared at
all and we're having a good time man
let's party I mean the bear is just like
thinking it's like a [__] all you can
eat buffet what
he's happy so everybody else must be
happy sure you know look at this look
what I found that because I found look
what I found in your house
that'd be kind of rad if he came down
and saw just a bear like looking at your
friends yeah
yeah the video I saw he was made up like
that and had his feet up in the air and
he had [__] buckets of [__] in his
hands
and it's just everywhere [__]
because their doors open they don't have
very good table manners
and he was happy you could tell you know
he said yes
look man look come get some come help me
with you you guys had such a good left
here there's plenty for everybody plenty
for everybody that's a nice cold KFC in
here some cold pizza
because you can you can you know oh
animals do smile you know it just
doesn't look the same but he's smiling
wow
look at this it's free
it's just laying right here right here
there's plenty come get some of this oh
my God they're funny
yeah there's a real famous clip of the
Russian dudes working out shirtless in
the [__] ice and [__] and next to him
is the bear jumped up and down [__]
helping him work out he's working out
too did you see that one
I think I know you're talking about the
Bears jumping up and down on a log was
and moving the logic
yeah he's working out it's freaking
funny
yeah
I mean yeah
[Laughter]
yeah the um yeah black bears like I said
are not and we've talked about this
before but they're they're not as
aggressive as Grizzly but I wouldn't
[__] with grizzly bears but that
actually the new I've been watching the
new season of
alone on Netflix and they stuck those
poor people like up in I think it's in
Canada somewhere and that place is
[__] Grizzly Central man it's like
every every single one of the
contestants has seen at least one
Grizzly yeah so far and one of them saw
a mountain lion too but like they've all
seen Grizzlies and The Grizzlies been
like around their camp and they're
having to put the meat way up in a tree
and all that other kind of [__] well
that you know that guy who got eaten by
the grizzly he'd he'd walk up and meet
Grizz you know until he ran into a bad
Grizz and he knew which Grizz was going
to kill him what do you say right there
thank you Jeffy art hey everyone just
walked into Tom talking about bears and
food while I just got back hanging out
and eating with my bear friends the
universe must be sitting besides
then he put like a little pride flag in
a little yeah
and you all some razors for yeah
shave that [__] down no man because then
they wouldn't be bad
then they would be um I don't know
Sphynx cats I don't know lose some
weight and they become otters oh my God
I saw a photograph the other day of
somebody taking pictures you know the
Sphinx cats it's hairless yeah except
usually they're real Sleek yeah this one
was like chubby though yeah I never saw
a chubby Sphinx cat before but it was I
mean it's probably not good for its
house but it was awfully cute like how
the little fat Sphynx cat now like Jenny
says she wouldn't [__] a Grizz I
wouldn't really willingly [__] with
Grizz either
but you know going up to Sequoia and
Redwood National forest and grow you
know uh went up there many times when I
was a kid you know my Lois there was
Grizz and I think I think it was brown
bears I don't know if they were Grizzly
but they were brown bears I think Grizz
were up there too
the problem is is that you can't show
any fear around those Bears if you show
Fear then you must be food
so that's the the that's that's the
problem
you see some [__] like that you can't
run from it
now the best advice I always heard is to
just look at the bear and sit down and
sit down on the ground with your feet
splayed out because that's the way a
bear sits and kind of put you back to
him and and then just pretend like
you're eating stuff off the ground
because that's how bear
that's bare body language for um I'm not
any threat to you I don't I'm not I
don't eat bear you know I eat stuff off
the ground I got my own [__] yeah but
I'm not really scared of you I got my
back to you you know
and evidently that works
and they'll kind of ignore you too
evidently once you do that it's like oh
all right
it's a man but he's like a bear and he's
like a pig it's a man bear pig
on the alone show
um the one guy this was the most
hilarious one the one guy who I can't
remember any of their names but the one
guy built the one that built the boat
and he was like really excited because
it was kind of a warm day and he took
all his clothes off and he was like
swimming around in the lake so as soon
as he got out the lake and he's all
naked and wet and everything like that
and then like a Grizzly comes like a rat
like toward him and it was like coming
around the side of the thing and he was
just he kept like yelling at it like hey
bear hey bear you know what I mean like
trying to get it to [__] and it was
just like not didn't interact huh it
well it just kept coming toward him like
I'm gonna see what's going he's like oh
[__] I don't think this is like good
because he looked like he was gonna come
investigate like see if he like eat him
and then finally he kept like yelling
and like trying and stuff but he had
like a um I guess they gave them like a
what do they call that thing like a bear
Banger thing like it just makes like a
loud noise and he did that a few times
and the bear was just like I don't give
a [__] and he like he didn't even Flinch
or anything but then after a while like
he did it one time and then the bear was
like okay fine and then like he wandered
off but the dude was funny because he's
like he was scared but he was just like
man of all the times for a [__]
berries like I'm standing here [__]
naked and soaking wet like a [__]
Grizzly he's like walking up wanting to
do [__] so I evidently Chris and brown
bear and Big Bear like Kodiak and [__]
it will test you
they'll walk up to you and then they'll
pass you and as they pass they'll lean
up against you
push and if you allow yourself to be
pushed they've just achieved dominance
and they might go back and eat you
so uh according to the dudes that
[__] about there living with them
when they push you you [__] push back
clean back like that like that that it's
not for free
I did and evidently they'll get a little
bit more respect
because a bear evidently push one
another with their shoulder just like an
actual classic bar like when you go to
the bathroom and like I don't like that
guy yeah
they can [__] throw their weight
around a little bit on you
I don't know I still wouldn't [__] with
him though well you won't have a choice
you know what I mean well yeah I didn't
follow him either I do because I'm not
going to a part of the world if you're
out there if you're in a place where
they are you they're going to put you
what did I just say I'm not gonna go out
I'm saying if you were out there you
might I mean sure it could happen like
some circumstance that I'm not planning
on I mean that could always happen but
I'm not planning on going out anywhere
and the thing about Grizzly Man was that
I mean he had lived with those bears for
a really long time and it wasn't one of
his bears that killed him
it was one of the cranky bears that he
was I mean so it was a sick bear and he
kind of he seemed to know
that that's how he was gonna die yeah
you know what I mean which is [__] up
it doesn't like make it good and
especially like I've heard the audio is
[__] horrifying yeah of him getting
killed because yeah they were making
like burner Herzog was making that uh
documentary about it yeah which I've
seen I've watched parts of it but I was
like I don't know if I want to watch the
whole thing or not even though I'm
pretty sure they don't they don't play
all of the audio in that I know the
director listened to it I know burner
hurts I'll listen to it and he said yeah
that's the most [__] up thing I ever
heard but um because his girlfriend got
eaten too yeah
and that was like the shitty thing
because she didn't even wanna
go up well she said I don't really think
he should go out because she she was
like getting worried about him you know
what I mean like you know one of his
Bears is gonna [__] eat you and it's
like yeah and it ain't her too so I
asked me if I've ever eaten Quail yeah
I've eaten Quail it's good it's kind of
like uh kind of like Cornish hand to me
a little bit yeah I've had it once and
that's what it reminded it's a little
like a little bitty cornish hen it's
mostly dark meat
um
well no I guess it isn't mostly it does
have a breast and I don't think but it's
like dark meat and it's like juicy and
tender
kind of like uh you know kind of like
cornish hen I guess that's the best way
to but look you remember we got those we
got those Cornish hens at Sam's right
yeah they were good like how many of
them were in a pack like four I think it
was four in a pack and it was what 20
bucks or not in a day it wasn't that it
wasn't it wasn't that much it was like I
think they were maybe it was 15 15 yeah
I think 15 I think it was 14.99 and it
was like four Cornish hens and I
remember those were like really good
like we cooked those up real good that
was a while back yeah I forgot how I did
those though yeah how did you do this
wasn't it kind of like a like a sweet
and sour or something I thought you just
did them regularly maybe I did oh no no
what I did I used that damn poultry
seasoning on there didn't I oh yeah I
couldn't remember I thought you put like
maybe thyme a rosemary or something like
that I think I used that uh poultry
seasoning
that came out of that
came out of that Shaker oh okay yeah I'm
talking about yeah
it had the yellow label on it I think
I'm out of that now it's just poultry
seasoning something you put on chicken
well yeah that's all it was good though
yeah I remember those being really good
yeah we should get those again when I
don't know how much they are now I'd
have to look
yeah Oscar said she noticed that I'd
been doing um Sam's a little bit
different
no for the same amount I can have all
the dry goods delivered and it's better
it's better um selection online because
I have the Sam's Plus card
S I don't have to drive down there they
only have to drive down there for the uh
fresh stuff meat and dairy well I told
you I mean [__] I I started doing Amazon
um Amazon Prime because I have Amazon
Prime and it's like I started doing that
like subscription for [__] that I use
all the time usually like till you know
toilet paper shampoo toothpaste razors
[__] like that that I'm always gonna use
and I just have them send me like x
amount and I have it for Pookie's uh
treats too like her treats and her food
so um and her little meat sticks so they
just send me like so many of it like
every three weeks or every six months or
however long but the thing about it was
that when I first started doing the
subscription I had
them sending me shampoo and conditioner
and I guess I clearly overestimated like
how much shampoo and conditioner I use
because
um they were sending shampoo and
conditioner like a box of four of each
thing it worked out though because we
were just stockpiling I still have a fun
time
and it's like you don't use it anymore
because you don't have any hair what I
do is I'll use it I'll put it in my damn
um hand cleaner yeah
I do use it though when I do like my
color touch-ups on the beach okay like
that when I shave I'm just gonna say
yeah
I use I use I still use that shampoo
because I had to put it on my head to
[__] shave in the shower okay that's
I still use it I thought you just used
like shower you got to have you got to
have some kind of lubricant on there to
shave shower gel that's another thing I
had a fun time I have I have a [__] ton
it's mostly
conditioner and shampoo I have so much
[__] conditioner I'm like how I was
looking in there the other day because
it's in my closet in my bathroom like
how do I get so much [__] conditioner
this is worth it though there's like
[__] 40 bottles of it in [__]
apocalypse can happen it would be
cleaning [__] up here
I got like six things or two
I like got like eight things of
deodorant yeah she was switching she was
like it's gonna be toothpaste now so
then we got arms
this whole stockpile of that although I
did notice this morning that I was on my
last pack of toilet paper so I probably
should get another case of that well
because every now and like Amazon like
reminds me it's like oh isn't it about
time to like buy that I was like oh
probably I'm like oh yeah I guess it is
Amazon knows say sly did you ever get on
HRT you were talking about getting on
HRT I know that that shit's expensive
that ends up [__] being like [__]
700 for your first visit and then 200 a
month I'm gonna hit you I'm gonna go
ahead and do a little plug right here on
the show to you men I found a really
good online site called steroidified.com
go on there and just open up a damn
account and [__] fill out the things
and learn the instruction you can pay
with Zell you can pay with Western
online Western Union you can pay with
crypto and they got everything you need
right there the test HCG
and all the videos you can learn how to
do it yourself
and you can get a two-month Supply damn
test for 120 dollars
steroidify.com
not a not a sponsor not a sponsor I'm a
customer
yeah one of these days you can get any
sponsors man yeah I was noticing I well
I was thinking about that the other day
because I was like well
I noticed that in the UK too
steroidified so I got UK listeners they
do the UK yeah go ahead I noticed that
the same companies sponsor most of the
other videos that I watch you know what
I mean isn't that interesting so who
does it I'm just saying that
most of the videos I watch in particular
yeah listen to what I'm saying most of
the videos that I watch in particular
that I'm just saying what what what what
she [__] with me
[Laughter]
I don't know where I am
well you know she's being mean to me
right I know it's so fun Tammy said
shutter should definitely sponsor
YouTube I know right although the thing
about I haven't watched a lot of stuff I
did watch skinamarink on shutter so I
have been watching it it's like I used
to watch it on there like um every week
but I just haven't had a chance to I
still have it you know and it's like I
still tell everybody to get it because
it's really good but you know yeah I
have seen
um
Jade the Libra she had shutter do a
couple of hers but what I was gonna say
was that most of the videos that I
watched like I said kind of the big more
horror Halloweeny kind of themed things
like uh you know Jade the Libra or Ryan
Hollinger or people like that they
usually have the same or um Nick doramio
they usually have the same
uh companies like sponsoring them one of
the big ones that's sponsoring them is
scentbird which is like a perfume
Subscription Service like it's you pay
so much a month and they send you and
tell them what kind you like and they
send you like a thing and I think like
there's also a wine Subscription Service
like like earbuds you know what I mean
that kind of stuff there's like shoes
but I've seen a couple of them that were
sponsored by shutter but not a lot I
don't know if shutter is sponsoring as
many videos as they were anymore I mean
I hope they're still doing good because
I really like
they they seem to have like been adding
a lot of really good [__] lately I've
the one thing I've always liked about
shutter is that
every time they add new [__] because
they add new [__] like every week they
always seem to take care to add really
new stuff and then like some older stuff
that's like you know Classics but then
they also have stuff that's like
slightly more obscure so they really
have a really well curated uh kind of
thing going on
are you guys watching the Super Bowl uh
no I didn't even know there's a Super
Bowl tonight I didn't even know
well no that's on is it Sunday I don't
know I don't know well I mean it's
usually on Sunday
isn't it Super Bowl Sunday I don't know
I don't know anything about sports
I don't know anything about sports I was
never into sports ball never never into
it it wasn't either I think it's just
wrong generation for it I don't know
anybody in my generation that
really into that
I mean they have some but that's like a
subculture now my dad and all his
friends they were big into that [__] but
I really never really saw any never
really understood the hype but never
really thought it was boring
yeah I always did too
I couldn't stand the sound I couldn't
stand the sound of the game on
television like oh and then the [__]
announcers and [__] it just yeah I just
didn't never like I was Associated it
with the
being stuck at home you're young yeah
your parents or your dad's watching it
you like you can't go anywhere you're
too young right you're like man yeah I
think that's why I didn't like it too
and it wasn't so much like sometimes
like my dad watched football sometimes
but mostly he was big in a NASCAR so it
was usually like NASCAR races like on
the weekends so I also hate the sound of
that and also like we grew I grew up in
Daytona which is you know [__] NASCAR
Central yeah because they have like the
big day track is the [__] the big track
there well and then and you know now
that I have work back in Daytona now
you know I passed the track like pretty
much every day like you know I see it
like over there and there is like so
that town is like built up so much
around that [__] track like that the
traffic is just [__] atrocious
nowadays yeah
God it's atrocious I mean it was
atrocious when I was younger too but
it's gotten like a lot worse but the
thing the thing about it they built a
lot of stuff there
I've noticed because I was like oh
that's new and that's new but it's like
it still kind of looks like a [__]
like it still really looks kind of like
crappy and
you know and white trash I haven't been
down there a long time even though they
built a lot of new stuff
yeah I mean uh the last time I saw that
area they had a whole bunch of new
housing uh complexes they were like way
nicer than this one the beautiful
entryways and stuff I don't know where I
think because people all work in Orlando
though
probably a lot of people that live in
Daytona they're working in Atlanta it's
weird because I always kind of did the
opposite like for a long time well you
know I lived in Daytona for a long time
but after I moved to Orlando I got a
couple jobs in Orlando but then I was
like working back in Daytona as well and
now I live over here and like work in
Daytona also
at least for now
um NASCAR isn't white trash It's Just
Sports on track yeah I'm just saying
Daytona was kind of it's is kind of like
white trashy and has been like ever
since I was a kid you know what I mean
and it still looks
because I knew like when I started
driving back there I was just kind of
like I knew they'd built a lot of stuff
so they did build oh I meant to tell you
that they built I just noticed it today
even though I've probably passed it like
every day like this past week
it's a restaurant at a bar but I think
it also has a shooting range in it okay
yeah
where it's on the corner of 92 which is
International Speedway Boulevard and
Bevel Road or no Tomoka Farms Road so
it's kind of like out by where the um
flea market is
I mean uh I didn't grow up here what the
[__] is it called I can't remember what
it's called
double shot double range double
Barrel double barrel that's what it's
called and I was like oh that's new I
think there used to be like a Texas
Roadhouse there or something like when I
used to live there but it's different
now I didn't grow up here so I don't I
don't really associate anything with any
like past memories or here I've just
showed up
because I spent about 15 years ago
and saw it as it is
and
as someone who's just come to this part
of the South
you can
see a big difference between
new Florida and old Florida
old Florida almost looks like old
Mississippi it looks like something out
of a dam
but red old Burt Reynolds movie but it's
all broken down now
so that's kind of what she's talking
about a lot of it still looks like that
still looks like that some of the
neighborhoods are ancient you know
houses from the 50s
and they're tiny by today's standards
tiny little houses real close to each
other bad condition
just fences and Gates around them and it
just they're just from another era you
know
that stuff's just kind of slowly fading
away you know
I mean the 20 30 years none of that'll
be here it's just funny because you know
I drive because I will not drive on I-4
I refuse so for you know and and going
from here to Daytona you don't
necessarily have to I-4 is a little bit
out of the way so I usually take 44
which is like a back like country
Highway and then I get on 92 which in
Daytona Beach that's International
Speedway Boulevard that's where the
speedway is but the funny thing about it
is that 92
is kind of like a major highway but the
road is like super shitty because it's
like it's old it's been there for like a
long time and it's concrete so when you
drive on it it's like
like that the whole time and it's been
like that like since I was a child and
the funny thing about it too is that
even though it's like a major highway
like all along the highway pretty much
all that there are are just these little
shitty it they it like bars like the
Oasis yeah it's like all like that and
then it's like Bail Bonds places because
like the prison is there like the county
jail is in DeLand right there and um you
know strip clubs
um you know little bait shops like it
just it all looks like that like still
like in 2023 it still looks like that
and so I thought it was funny that I was
like because I've been driving that and
I haven't driven that way for a long
time and I was like most of it's just
Woods still but you drive by and I'm
just like oh my God like [__] Soft
Tails strip club is still there and like
that bait shop is still there that's
been there since I was a kid and you
know know it's just like this old this
crankulous like broken down old bar and
it's like still open or like a little
package store and stuff like that it's
like so [__] funny that it's like
they they didn't really build they built
new stuff like in Daytona
but a lot of it's still kind of like
looks kind of old and broken down but I
did notice that new place that new
restaurant yeah there was something else
there when I lived there I think it was
a Texas Roadhouse or one of those like
old like you know Texas Steakhouse type
things
um but yeah I'm pretty sure it said it
said restaurant and bar and then the
logo yeah it was called double barrel on
the logo logo looked like a like a rifle
like a rifle barrel most of the new
stuff and I think it said with shooting
range most of the news it's like okay
which is a lot of it I would say more
than half
of the Orlando area area is pretty new
because it's growing quickly and it
makes it looks like a porn movie because
that's where they're filming most of
those porn movies is here here in this
area
which is ultra modern looking stuff with
palm trees in the background that's uh
is
that's the way most and and there's
swimming pools in the backyards and
that's where you know like the place
where we used to live they're like that
um
so it's nice it's real nice
there's there's money here now there
didn't used to be
but it's just changed uh this moved up
in the world more talents moved here
economy's gotten a lot better
um than it was uh just
the Old South that we grew up in in
[__] the 80s and shit's gone it's
gone there are still some people from
that era that are living mentally in
that era they're hanging out over there
at the Oasis where I hang out at and
talking to them is like [__]
experiencing a Time Warp I mean well
yeah that's why I thought it was funny
like driving back to Daytona because a
lot of the places that I remember from
my childhood are still there and they
still look the same yeah the thing is
though is it's irrelevant I mean it
sounds brutal but those areas
and those people in those areas are are
irrelevant
they're they're mostly kind of retired
they're aging out uh they have no idea
what's going on they only know their
little local area and they're wild they
watch television
which that's just like
mind-numbing to me but like my dad my
dad still watches television he doesn't
really know how to use the internet
and talking to him's like talking to
somebody who's been living in a fishbowl
because the only input they get is
through those old channels and those
channels have gotten worse recently the
programming on them this [__] trash
you know
generic trash and the information
sources are terrible on television
so they just they don't know what's
going on they don't know anything
it was just funny because we didn't back
when we depended on television for
information we didn't realize how how
much we did not know
because there's nothing of substance
really on television it wasn't even back
then
well it wasn't super into it back then
even like I said I was more into like
music and yeah weird movies I remember
in the 90s
after I got out of the army going into
that bad house
and turn on television
and uh it was just broadcast TV
I had one of those little bitty color
televisions I turn on the television
at night when I came home and it would
be just nothing but Jerry Springer and
Ricky Lake on it [__] like two
o'clock in the morning
and just nothing on television of any
substance just a total waste of time
real depressing
and then ads for [__]
party chat lines I remember those
and and thinly veiled phone sex
commercials they weren't even they
weren't even thinly veiled they weren't
they weren't they weren't now I've heard
I did I don't think they showed this one
in in Florida markets but I've heard
like in other markets they had one that
was like um water sports specific so it
was like one for people that like to get
peed on yeah
and they even kind of said that where
did I hear about that I think it was
like in the midwest somewhere and it was
like I can't remember what the number
was it was 1-800 like something filthy
sounding and it's like the the extra
P is for extra P or something like that
it's like yeah people like to get peed
on
um so I was like okay I never saw that
in Florida but okay we had other kind of
uh phone sex lines but they were mostly
pretty generic yeah you know you just
get like the generic woman with like you
know the the soft focus lens like with
lingerie going comments like you know
what I mean like they didn't do I didn't
see anything that was like really
specific like there wasn't any BDSM ones
or you know I don't know furry porn they
didn't have that back then I mean they
had it but they wouldn't have advertised
it on TV
uh Sly said do you guys Bowl
no I I used to go bowling sometimes
every now and then like me and my
brother and uh and stuff he used to get
when we were kids and I actually used to
like it I sucked at it but like I did
have more Sports
because I'm not very coordinated but um
I used to like going though I used to
like going
I used to go bowling sometimes and I
used to go roller skating
and
yeah not a big Sports person though not
a big Sports person
um
so I said television is all about images
I love old 70s 80s movies unless it's a
documentary
um yeah I really like
some things I like about I was like I
like old 70s TV movies like horror
movies because some of those were really
good like I like those
and I like old TV shows but
I don't know they're really they're not
the same so you can almost kind of like
you know as one nowadays you can kind of
like approach them from a different
they're almost like a different genre I
don't know it's like kind of hard to
explain
because I I don't know like I I watched
some of the ones because I've been
watching
like over on my scare Salon Channel
which I really need to like post some
more stuff on there but like I said I
haven't really had time I'm gonna do I
think I'm gonna do a crime Memorial
video tomorrow I've gotta plan down and
everything I just haven't recorded it
yet but um
I've been watching Thriller the 60s
Anthology show with Boris Karloff and
I'm also starting to do Night Gallery
the Rod Serling one I did the pilot but
I'm you know then I'm gonna do like each
episode I love because I love Night
Gallery
but the thing about it is like watching
those I love those and they're like
really comforting but because they're
you know quote unquote old and we've
seen so much stuff subsequently that
um you know use the same tropes so it's
like you can pretty much they're all
like pretty predictable at this point
because like oh you know this is gonna
go like XYZ because we've seen
so much stuff like that like
subsequently
so but I don't know it doesn't really
take my enjoyment away from it
even though I always know what's gonna
happen you know what I mean
Zach says yeah you call the line and
then you're actually talking to 300
pound Patty from Wisconsin whose husky
voice from the whole Earth where she's
supposed through
that was I mean I have to bad respect
those those women back then they were
kind of like
um really on the Vanguard of like the
work from home hustle Trends you know
what I mean doing the phone sex having
the people call the like their trailer
or whatever and then like I'm honestly I
admire people that could do that because
I don't think I could do that without
cracking up
you know what I mean I would just like
crack up and it would ruin the whole
thing unless that was the fetish
if your fetish is you want me to make
fun of you and then like not be able to
keep a straight face like it's just like
keep cracking up and everything
like while I'm talking about it then um
then yeah then I'm your girl but other
than that no I wouldn't be able to keep
a straight face like doing that
Oscar said Jen reviewing all the Night
Gallery episodes would be great one of
my favorites is a little black bag oh
yeah that was a good one yeah I've seen
the whole Night Gallery Series
um probably two or three times through
um but I just got the idea even though
I'm not done with Thriller yet like I'm
only halfway through Thriller because I
didn't realize that they had 60 like 67
episodes I think it is it's like some
ridiculous amount and they're long
they're like an hour each
so I'm kind of getting through those and
so I said well I'm gonna start doing
Night Gallery too because I've been
wanting to do that and I still want to
do colchach the Night Stalker as well
like I did the two TV movies but I
haven't done the series yet so I'm gonna
get into all of those eventually but
like I said it'll probably take a while
because I don't have a lot of time and
honestly I still want to put up another
book review too I have been reading
because I have my Kindle
app on my phone so on my lunch hours at
work I've been reading
novels you know so because I'm trying to
like keep up with stuff so I'm almost
about 75 of the way through a novel that
I'm like doing it's called the house
that fell from the sky it's kind of like
a lovecraftian
kind of deal I'm kind of kind of into it
it's pretty good it's pretty good I
can't remember like um who wrote it
though
but that's probably the next one I will
do but that might be like another few
days because
I gotta finish reading the book and then
I gotta script out the review and all
that kind of stuff so you know
so I said um I've seen all the night
galleries the spin-off shows I love Kung
Fu TV series oh yeah I haven't seen Kung
Fu in a while yeah I would wouldn't mind
seeing kung fu yeah yeah maybe we should
rewatch Kung Fu at one point yeah
because I haven't seen them all
maybe I have but I was a little kid
right it's just I don't remember them
um
I think I saw recently like in the last
five or six years the first couple
episodes but I but I don't remember
actually completing it
yeah what was that guy's name
it's karate yeah yeah David Carradine I
think his name's Dave was
he made a whole he made a whole career
over faking a faking a Chinese accent
really yeah well yeah
he [__] put out a video a Tai Chi
video with that accent that [__]
was from California
well you know they're like hey go to
California like go to Hollywood and
reinvent yourself yeah as it's probably
worth the Chinese white person it's
probably where Steven Seagal got the
idea that he could just do any exit and
get away with it
I mean to an extent he does get away
with it it's not like anybody like
shoots him in the face or anything right
I mean people make people make fun of
him about it he's Italian he
he other than that there's really any
consequences he he's whatever race or
ethnicity he needs uh when he's talking
to somebody else if he's talking to a
black dude he becomes black
if somebody asks him about martial arts
he becomes Chinese
I wonder if I was talking to him if you
start talking like me if you start
talking about Mafia stuff he goes into
an Italian accent he [__]
cheesy as [__] he's from Michigan he's a
Jewish guy from Michigan
but he's whatever he's whatever race
he's got to be
to achieve the Asian experience
if you guys know what I'm talking about
the Asians we're we're all trying to
we're all trying to obtain our own
agency but look man look
there's been some progress on on the
Steven Seagal front though has there
yeah I've been seeing some more recent
videos of him on YouTube and he is kind
of like having a sense of humor yeah you
told me that it's like I'm not entirely
sure I believe it but because he seemed
like so up his own ass he looks like
he's developed a little bit of sense of
humor I think he's embraced his meme a
little bit and he's going to be in um
Expendables 4.
now if if he's gonna be inexpendables
for and they like Lampoon his whole
shtick through the whole movie well they
kind of do that then I well I know but
then I will know that he's actually like
embraced yeah they probably will because
uh when whenever like uh anybody shows
up in an Expendables movie they do kind
of lampoon
I mean they even ampute Arnie a little
bit when he's [__] doing his secret
mission and
he's helping him out you know uh helping
him Escape
in Expendables three he goes Everybody
Get To The Choppa he does the get to the
Shopper line oh my goodness yeah get to
the chopper yeah I mean it's funny but
it seems like low hanging yeah yeah they
do low hanging food
it's The Expendables they're gonna do
little some fan service and I'm just
kind of like I don't know if I want to
go yay or ah yeah they'll even have
Harrison Harrison Ford goes in there and
acts like a [__] hard guy being a CIA
dude like from what was what was that uh
series that he did uh it was like a Tom
Clancy oh yeah yeah he plays that guy
executive decision yeah he basically the
[__] movie was that basically if you if
you're an old action guy and you're in
The Expendables you're gonna have to
reprise Your Role you're gonna have to
like do the line because everybody's
like yeah you have to do it you're
contractually obligated but that that is
the I love the Expendable series and
that is the tone of the expandables
right that's his tone you know
I don't know like stuff like that just
makes I don't know
I feel a certain kind of way about that
is nostalgia right but it's like like I
said I'm not a super nostalgic person
and a lot of times too I'm just like God
that's just like so easy it's like so
easy that it's just like it just kind of
makes me want to roll my eyes more than
anything else you know what I mean
because I'm like yeah everybody knows
that joke
you'll never get it Jenny that's action
movies well no I get it I get it yeah
well there's nothing to get yeah that's
the argument that I'm making well
there's actually there's nothing to get
action movies is referring back to other
action movies you know
Jenny Jenny's her ex-husband forced her
to watch all the damn action movies
she's she's not all of them but mostly
the Chuck Norris ones and a lot of the
early because he was really into Chuck
Norris and um so I've seen all of the
Chuck Norris movies and I'm not even
kidding I've seen all of them multiple
times I've seen several Chuck Norris
movies there were a couple that were
good I will I will go to bat for silent
rage that was actually a deal well
because it was kind of more a horror
movie it was like it was like a serial
killer I didn't see it uh the Octagon is
also decent I think he's not a good
actor I think I saw the octagon and I
remembered it being boring
I no I liked that one I liked that one
the other ones were stupid but like um
silent rage was good because it was like
I said it was like a horror movie that
just kind of happened to have Chuck
Norris in it and the Octagon I remember
liking that one but like the other ones
I was just like God this is so dumb
I haven't seen enough of Chuck Norris
[__] to really uh [__]
to really know what to say about him it
just Oscar said a force of one was okay
uh yeah yeah yeah that's right that one
was all right I remember
from what I remember of Chuck Norris
movies
I always remembered walking away from
them thinking that they were kind of
generic and unsatisfying yeah
and they're kind of they're they also
have that
they showcased Chuck Norris well a dude
who is not interesting right he's like
not a good actor and I don't like the
whole like maybe this is different now
but I kind of feel like a lot of his
movies back in the day he just seemed he
comes off as like a little bit he's very
wooden and then he also comes off as
like kind of like a sanctimonious douche
yeah a little bit like he's just very
I don't really like these movies where
like the action hero it's like and he's
right about everything and it's like I
don't know yeah you know what I mean and
I've seen enough of it and I kind of
feel like he always came off like that
now there's one of them that I did
remember seeing
me and Mike Kowalski up in Michigan
looking
um grabbed her knows who I'm talking
about
me Mike Kowalski and our friend [__]
ninja Jim which I've told stories about
Ninja gym before okay he was like
something straight out of [__] Karate
Kid all right
we watched a Chuck Norris movie on VHS
over at Mike's house
and then after that we [__]
smuggled a [__] case of beer out of
the back of the [__] 7-Eleven we were
underage but we got it out of there
and uh
the movie was called Delta Force yeah
I've seen that one yeah Delta Force and
I remember sometimes I remember being
amused by Delta Force
it was like a really bad Rambo movie
yeah
but when you're a kid
there's something about you is that you
you you can you can still buy into some
freaking premises that you don't realize
how much how much
these stories strain credulity you know
the situations behind them you just
accepted it for what it was yeah you
didn't really go wait a minute hold on
well could a dude really do that or
would a government actually ask this
dude to help that way why this dude I
mean okay [__] like that I would argue
though like look I'm a horror movie fan
horror movies are all about unbelievable
premises
so when you watch something you have to
like give the movie some room it's like
you have to be like okay for the for the
duration of this movie we're going to
pretend that ghosts exists or we're
gonna pretend that like there's a
lovecrafty and tentacled hellbeast like
coming you know what I mean so you have
to kind of like suspend your disbelief
so I kind of feel like action movie fans
do that too but I there's kind of like a
fine line between watching an action
movie where they're just like yeah we
know this is ridiculous we're just
having a fun time we're just
entertaining you and watching an action
movie where you're kind of expected to
take it seriously and I kind of feel
like Chuck Norris's movies not all of
them but I think a lot of them fell on
the other side of that line where he was
like very much trying to be taken
seriously like you know I'm very serious
like action movie star and I was like
and I know that he can really do karate
and all that other kind of [__] like I'm
not saying that but I'm just saying that
like his movies like one he's not a good
actor okay it's like I'm sure he he
would admit that too yeah maybe he
wouldn't I don't know he got back well
he did well you would after a while
because he was very very wooden he's not
very charismatic
um you know what I mean so you know you
never buy any of his emotions like when
he's like kicking people in the face
fine I remember seeing he had a
television program called Walker Texas
Ranger yeah and I remember seeing that
was it was in the 90s when it was
ridiculous it was [__] was ridiculous it
was a ridiculous [__] show Walker
Texas Rainer but I remember being amused
by it and then I and that he was good in
it from what I remembered uh it was a
long time ago though he always just came
Acro I think one of the things that
always kind of pissed me off about him
was he always came across as like kind
of like a goody two-shoes he is that's
what I'm saying and it's like and
because my ex-husband was like really
into him and so I knew a lot about his
personal like more than I ever wanted to
know about like Chuck Norris's life but
it's like so yeah he's like very
religious and he's very you know he's
like he won't let any people swear
around him and stuff just like yeah we
can't hang sorry I I can't hang out with
people like that it's just it's too
stressful so you know what I mean yeah
because I can't relax around people like
that I remember the scene back then they
stressed me out
this this was an ERA if you're a young
person if you're a millennial or
something you will never understand the
80s
even though the 80s is coming back into
Vogue you know what I mean they're you
have you have young people having this
came back into it's been back in dude
you have young people having feelings of
nostalgia for an era they never lived in
but I understand the Nostalgia because
they're they're watching those old
movies and and yeah it was kind of cool
it was very well it was an ERA that was
analog and they've never experienced
yeah a non this is the last analog
generation yeah so it's like you can see
where it's coming from like they're like
they're kind of like oh that might have
been kind of neat you know I mean
because they didn't experience it in
that era
that no internet television was unset
unsatisfactory you could go the best
thing going was [__] Blockbuster or
[__] what was the other one [__]
uh uh uh New York videos no no I went to
movie gallery yeah what was the red and
white one
movie time
anyway you had to rent VHS and that was
a better source of entertainment
information was going to VHS and you got
to see movies that they wouldn't play on
television
well it was a it was a it was an era of
Mystery
we play video games but the best video
games were at 7-Eleven
stand up arcade units and you had to pay
money to [__] play them
home home video games you paid them you
played them but they weren't as good as
a [__]
cons as a [__] arcade game that was
like we consider it to be a real game
so when you went to 7-Eleven or an
arcade or mostly 7-Eleven to go play
this thing be usually behind
the video games like you're playing the
video games you turn around there's a
magazine rack all right in that magazine
rack they had all kinds of [__] one of
the sections was a karate section they
have martial arts
so the movies the video games and the
magazines there was a martial arts Nexus
started to happen in in the 80s that's
where Karate Kid came from you know that
they jumped in halfway that was like
halfway through it
um video games like [__] Street
Fighter and they had Ellen it was just
called [__] karate or Kung Fu I don't
remember he had the two fighters one in
red one one in white
fighting games well
we were very confused about what reality
was
because
you could pick up a magazine
and about Kung Fu and read some [__] in
there about throwing cheese balls and
dudes doing these [__] impossible
sounding feats
and because it was in a magazine you'd
tend to believe it because [__] they
printed it it must be true
and that was just the thinking of the
time
we stumbled across this [__] movie in
this era
called Bloodsport
it has Gene called Jean-Claude Van Damme
in it
and it was this wild tale about this guy
who goes on this [__]
goes to this fight on the other side of
the [__] planet and it's a fight to
the death and fights all these dudes and
at the very end of that [__] movie it
came up
and then it
said Frank Ducks had this many fights
and this many [__]
then it gave dates and how many
victories he had and we were like wait a
minute hold on this is a true story this
is a true [__] story
foreign
we gotta watch this [__] again I should
say anything this is a true story
because it the way it ended man they
[__]
what you gonna do yeah well we're like
what the [__] so we go back we're
playing street fighter and [__] the
7-Eleven and next thing we know in those
[__] karate magazines hey man look
Frank Ducks that's him that's the dude
he really existed he really did that
[__] wow what a badass that really
happened
well
that's not who Frank Ducks was yeah
we did a whole show about that yeah well
it wasn't entirely about him yeah yeah
yeah it was the Bushido show it's
[__] [__] yeah yeah when he
claimed to be some kind of Delta Force
secret agent [__] operative and all
this [__] well like I said it was
easier back then you could say what
people did her [__] check couldn't
check the [__] was bullshitter
yeah you could just say whatever you
wanted
now this is the thing I wanted I want to
know the director of [__] Bloodsport
did he know was [__] probably he's
like had to have known I'm just making a
movie
all movies are [__] yeah
I mean to an extent I think even Stephen
King said that it's like you know even
if something is based on a true story
it's like when you're writing a
fictional like I'm making a movie about
it it's fiction yeah even if it's based
on a real thing because it's Gotta It's
gotta look good on screen well yeah he's
like he said the very medium
fictionalizes that's what he said that's
very medium itself fictionalizes right a
good way of putting it that's what he
said I'm gonna remember that too I
remember that I'm pretty sure that's
exactly what he said right it's
unavoidable
looks at it even if you kept it close to
what really happened the audience
experiences it and they internalize what
happened and then they see it in their
own mind and change it to what yeah well
and you think like just making it a
movie it's like those aren't the actual
people doing the [__] exactly it's not
exactly the way it happens but you know
as badass as I look I would look seven
times this badass if I had a soundtrack
wherever I went I always kind of wanted
I'm walking this watch you know and and
depending on whatever my mood is
sometimes this [__] 70s you know
[__] Funk or whatever and sometimes
it's [__] something like out of Star
Wars if you have a [__] soundtrack
[__] gets a lot better if you got a
score behind it well yeah because
everything looks like like some
significant [__] significantly it's epic
[__] when you're just walking around
silence yeah it's not good it's really
that's not good
just to show you that's why I really
wouldn't want to review in movies I
really listened to the [__] score
I'm listening for a score or try or
noticing the lack of a score
because really that's where the emotion
is it's telling you how you should feel
and if it's done right that is how you
will feel watch Conan one
with that badass [__] score all right
it tells you exactly how to feel
and you do feel that with that classical
score going back there yeah I mean a
good score absolutely manipulates your
emotions yes and I'm not saying that
like in a negative way you know that's
what it's supposed to do
and the thing about it is that and it
and even though I'm aware of it it still
works on me yeah like [__] man I could
watch a [__] Pixar movie and they
have like a sad moment and like the big
swell of music comes up and like your
eyes tear up it's just it happens like
you know unless you're a psychopath I
guess
um Zach's talking about Chuck Norris
he's not very good looking either no
he's not uh he kind of looks like
someone's drunk uncle knowing if I
server for the holidays yeah I kind of
feel like uh yeah here comes Uncle Chuck
and he's gonna come in there and like
complain that everybody's swearing and
what are you why are they why are they
like legalizing marijuana and all that I
kind of feel like he'd be that kind of
[__] like you invited Murphy for
Thanksgiving he would just like piss and
moan about everything Hugo says he likes
John Carpenter scores I like his scores
too I do too and it's because they're
they're always they're kind of minimal
in certain ways like the one for the
thing was just dude
and that [__] worked man you're
constantly what well it was a whole vibe
right and then you know of course
Halloween uh and then Escape From New
York [__] great great theme even
though it's kind of like almost sounds
like something from an old cop movie
like [__] you know or
night court or something what is it
kind of sounded a little bit it had a
new wave vibe to it back in those days
he was using synthesizers and stuff but
if it was good though it was good
hmm no I kind of I I I like when the
score is
I feel like ideally that's kind of the
shitty thing you're kind of in a shitty
position if you're like writing a score
for a movie I feel like because you want
the score to marry
perfectly with the visuals you know what
I mean and everything has to work as one
you almost want the score to be like not
noticeable because you don't want it to
like over
you know to like overwhelm the visuals
or like be distracting
so you just kind of want it in the
background
but you want it to be noticeable but not
which I imagine is like really really
difficult to do
because a lot of times I don't notice
the score unless it's really really good
or unless it's really jarring
like it doesn't really fit or unless
there's not one like sometimes sometimes
I notice that and sometimes I don't it
depends on the movie you know what I
mean because some I feel like some
movies
don't need a score or you know or a
minimal score like works really well but
then like some movies I really like like
a big like orchestral storm score I
think that I talked about a movie what
was the movie that I talked about not
too long ago that I mentioned I really
really like the score that was like a
piano score [__] now I can't remember
what it was
but
what the [__] movie was that that I was
talking about
it wasn't the last one that I did
because Skinnamarink didn't have a score
because that was kind of like a like a
different thing but I thought it was
super important I mean oh I remember
what it was it was uh Blood Simple
that's right uh the first um Coen
Brothers movie yeah and um I mentioned
that I really really liked the score for
that I noticed it but I thought it
worked really well with it like it was
kind of like a somber like piano score
and I was like really really into it
like I just remembered like really
liking the that's a great movie by the
way if you like the Coen brothers that's
their first movie Blood yeah if you're a
filmmaker you don't have a score you're
you're hobbled you're gonna have to be
real
careful about your edit
and things that have to be has to be you
have to do a master class
and edit to get around the fact that you
don't have a score and but although
there are some there were some cool
[__] Indie flicks that I've seen that
I don't think there was a score at all
yeah sometimes you don't need one it
depends on what the movie is you can't
get around it but it's gonna have a it's
gonna have a weird tone and you have to
work with that tone
it's best to have a score
me I always love a classical score but
it's only for certain kinds of movies
it's got to be something that's Epic if
it's yeah I think it's going to be
classical well in a classical score is
better in a lot of ways because it
doesn't your movie doesn't date as much
it should be good forever because I kind
of feel like sometimes you know you see
a movie that was made in the 70s or 80s
and they're like oh we want a very up to
the minute score or soundtrack or
something like that and now it just
sounds like yeah really dated Star Wars
A New Hope was originally gonna have a
disco score imagine how that would have
sucked which that would have been
hilarious it had to suck they talked
about that they go no I gotta go
classical and that worked that [__]
score is epic
then you can watch A New Hope as old as
that movie is and it's still it still it
still holds up that's what I mean that's
why it's always best to go with that
although like I said it doesn't always
work like with the movie but I kind of
feel like it's better to go with
something more like that like more
traditional Conan and a barbarian that
[__] holds up that movie
it's like watching an opera but it's
because it's got that classical score
long shots and
shots of scenery you know I'm [__]
nature riding horses that kind of stuff
and then the interior shots and all that
that heavy
with the [__] big tympanies going it
just that didn't date
you know which oh that always kind of
reminded me of like um The Rite of
Spring a little bit wasn't that was that
Stravinsky I can't remember
uh Mr 80 it said blood simple's piano
intro is awesome yeah I agree and very
Philip Glass by the way Philip glass's
1998 score for Dracula is fantastic
didn't Philip Glass do the score also
for Candyman the original from 1992
because I really liked that as well yeah
I like Philip glass's scores but yeah I
remember I don't remember who did Blood
simples score I think I mentioned it on
the review but I remember like really
really liking it I tend to like like you
said kind of more classical scores
or piano based scores
um depending on what the movie is
he mentioned Dracula
a couple months back we reviewed Spanish
Dracula 1935 or 6 I don't remember no 31
it was it was the same year that the
same year the older one same well it was
it was Universal same universe it was
just made for the Spanish yeah they
didn't dub they just made a whole other
movie with Spanish actors and stuff with
the same sets same sets but it was just
a different director and the camera
actually moved through the scenery uh
the edit was better
that was a better telling of the story
I thought in some ways it was yeah and
it was a lot more 3D the uh because the
camera would move through the set so
you'd get a better feel that it wasn't
just some kind of a cheap backdrop that
it was actually like a castle
um if you've seen the old Bell to go see
Dracula see the Spanish Dracula
along with it
it's not Bella it's another guy
playing Dracula
he has a different interpretation of the
character
I kind of prefer Bella but this guy's
good too he's real good uh yeah it's a
different it's just a different
interpretation of it and he hadn't seen
he didn't see
Bella's version everybody saw there did
it their own way
and the Spanish guy what do you remember
what his name was
he was a famous actor yeah I mentioned
it on the show but I can't remember it
offhand
there were certain things about him I
liked better
than Baylor but Baylor man he had that
role that with the [__] accent and
[__]
and he's some people say well he's kind
of comical
I didn't really think so he was kind of
coming off as crazy like [__] he was
still intent uh sinister
and he just seemed kind of
and it was
they showed his Brides a little bit more
Dracula's Brides he had three more
female vampires they showed them
I liked them I liked the Spanish Mina a
little bit better
yeah I did as well yeah well she had
like a she seemed like more of a
character yeah you know what I mean and
the Spanish Renfield I think was better
yeah that was a pretty good Renfield
yeah [__] he had more lines
yeah a lot of the parts were expanded
yeah there's a lot more it was longer it
was longer
although I gotta say I liked uh
um I liked Bella's
Bayless looking uh be you know the
Beatrix to look into the mirror scene
yeah Bella's handling of it I think was
better yeah than the Spanish hand I
think he hit it with a cane and it
didn't quite look
it didn't look natural
but still they're both great movies
John rumbleslop said we used to roller
skate the Star Wars Disco
man I used to go when I was a little kid
we used to go uh you know grew up in
Daytona Beach and we you all used to go
to Starlight which was the big roller
skating rink back in the 80s
and I would wear my I had my own roller
skates
they were white with little blue wheels
and I would go with my gray Calvin Klein
leg warmers and my little feathered
headband
and all my cool 80s paraphernalia like
in the actual 80s I was I was 10 you
guys Mr 88 came through I think he's
talking about Spanish Dracula's name his
name is Carlos Villa real yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's right you said the Spanish
Dragon was a lost film until the print
was discovered in the late 70s yeah I
think we mentioned that so we did a
review of it we recommend it if you guys
haven't seen it man see Spanish Dracula
it's for free on what services it was it
was on to be I don't think it's there
anymore though because I think like um a
couple weeks after we reviewed it
somebody said oh I looked on tubing it's
not there anymore and then I looked and
both of the Draculas were gone so I
guess they were just on there for like a
limited amount of time it always has to
do with like the rights and [__] like
that yeah Oscar Perez is saying that uh
the stragoy and blood vessel [__] it
was kind of disappointing that he never
physically attacked anybody yeah that's
that's right for something that was so
frightening looking the way that
character was it'd been better to see
him do something like that but I think
what they were trying to do
is they were trying to demonstrate all
the stragoy powers
you know what I mean every time he did
something he did it he did it to this
tragoy way which I thought was [__]
cool because I didn't know anything
about a struggling when I saw the movie
Not only was he a vampire that could do
weird [__] like cross-breeding with
living and dead people
now they could do that but he was also a
sorcerer and I was like whoa he says he
he can [__] do magic
he cast spells like a witch that's
[__] awesome
he's all the monsters wrapped in one
yeah
Sebastian said uh some Dario Argento
films such as suspirian phenomena like
uh yeah talking about scores honestly
the score for Suspiria
um I will just listen to that without
even watching the movie and the thing
about Dario argento's scores which
mostly Goblin did back in the day
is that in a lot of ways they were very
bombastic and they were um you know
almost kind of like made to draw
attention to themselves but in the case
of Dario argento's movies especially his
earlier ones that were actually good
um I think that worked in its favor
because the whole vibe of it was just
like very over the top and very operatic
so you know particularly Suspiria which
was just like these bright vivid colors
and like all these like crazy like
really gory like set pieces and things
and so I think like that over the top
score really worked but the Suspiria
theme especially that main theme God I
[__] love that I've like I said I've
listened to that like just as a regular
ass song which I don't usually do with
movie scores because I don't usually
like movie scores enough
to listen to them without the movie
attached but Suspiria is one that I
actually own and that I listen to like a
lot especially that main theme I love
that
but um I was gonna say too since we were
talking about movie scores
I was thinking to myself what would
what's a good
um a movie with a really good soundtrack
as in not necessarily the score but
songs in there
um okay uh [__] Romeo and Juliet
yeah
but I'm talking about the uh Leonardo
Dicaprio and Claire Danes no no Claire
Danes wasn't it was a clear dance uh
yeah yeah it was okay I love that movie
I have it in steel book
some people like you like the [__] I
love [__] uh that's baz Lerman man
yeah yeah and it's he made Moulin Rouge
yeah and I was like wait a minute you
know some of this [__] it's in a modern
context like Central America sex Central
America warring cartels basically
and some of the themes you know are kind
of like modern I was like I can't be man
that's [__] Shakespeare you know what
I mean they can't be talking about drugs
they can't be talking about gay stuff of
course they can no yeah that's exactly
what they were talking about yeah of
course I went back and checked
and Shakespeare [__] is timeless that's
why they're still doing his [__] now
Shakespeare on the Slick [__] said
all kinds of [__] you weren't supposed
to say and he was all clever about like
the way he said about it you know what's
his name mccursio Mercury Mercutio
um
uh
Romeo's uh one of Romeo's Chief friends
and bodyguards
uh he's played by a black actor I don't
remember what that guy's name was but he
comes to the party dressed in Drag
and says all kinds of stuff on the Slick
it kind of sounds gay and then he dies
for Romeo and then he goes [__] him
curse on both your houses and all kinds
of [__]
yeah that was a gay undertone he was in
love with [__] with Romeo they left it
deniable because you couldn't come out
and say that
back in those days well there was that's
what it was I mean there was a whole
subculture up until probably the 70s
when it became like acceptable to be out
as well I mean it wasn't super
acceptable in the 70s but at least it
started to become more acceptable but
until like they had a whole subculture
they had their like vernacular and stuff
like that because she couldn't come out
and say like certain things so you
always had to like obliquely right refer
to things because Mercutio was telling
um telling Romeo and one of the scenes
he's like yeah you have all this good
life and [__] but me my life it sucks
because I can never be who I am and I
can never love who I love type of deal
remember that remember and and like
what's he talking about you know what I
mean
he's in love with Romeo yeah yeah I mean
it's obvious to Modern audiences it was
probably obviously back then back then
but they had to you had to skirt it
right because they had sensors basically
yeah so but that's exactly what it was
so the movie is correct
and then well that's what I'm saying
that's why they're still doing
interpretations of Shakespeare nowadays
his [__] is like Timeless yeah and then
there was a bunch of drug references in
there yeah and they're in the movie but
they're in the play too yeah it's just
that they don't know exactly what drugs
they were talking about but it is some
kind of drug but yeah drugs are right
they were talking about look man we go
to this party you need to [__] talk
to this Angel and this angel on your
lips will do this and that and you will
have a basically you will trip balls and
the party will be great basically what
they tell them yeah we don't know what
drug they're talking about
it was something that made you trip out
yeah
it's like I said people for thousands of
years they they did they knew all about
that stuff like I said they just use
different terminology for it and it
wasn't
it's not so much the behavior that
changes it's how
um Society at large reacts to it and
like sometimes you have to like talk
around it instead of just like coming
out and saying it that's pretty much the
only difference you know what I mean but
if you haven't seen that Romeo and
Juliet I recommend that
I recommend that highly
um what's the name basil what baslerman
baslerman
Leonardo DiCaprio back I would also
recommend Moulin Rouge because I [__]
love that movie yeah Ewan McGregor and
yeah Nicole Kidman and they were singing
in it that one too but I like Romeo bet
Romeo and Juliet better they're very and
well baslerman made that Elvis movie
that yeah so yeah which was also really
good he's very into
extra he's very extra make it big like
make it put more glitter on it put more
like which it's a lot
um but if you know that's what you're
getting it's like he's very enthusiastic
he's putting on a show right like it's a
theater production right and you know uh
Moulin Rouge and and and and and and
Moulin Rouge and Romeo and Juliet were
supposed to be theater Productions so it
works well for those stories yeah I'm
just saying you have to know that going
into it because otherwise you'll be like
holy crap Romeo and Juliet great
soundtrack
a great 90s soundtrack
uh [__] man [__] I don't remember
everybody was on it but it's just rock
music mostly there's some soul in it
though too yeah
um uh they do uh a different version of
Purple Rain remember like a like yeah
that's right like a gospel version of
Purple Rain uh
Kevin Friday's Angel is in there yeah
it's almost I love that song
and then um
what a massive attack was in it wasn't
it Massive Attack I think it might have
been yeah it's been a while since I've
seen it I don't really remember yeah
because like it was Prodigy not prodigy
oh maybe it was you might have been in
there
see I'm not like a big fan of like 90s
music so I mean I like some of it Nine
Inch Nails might have done something oh
you want to hear something funny so like
today at work like the guy I work with
he's on Friday he's like he's does DJ
day right and he'll play like all
different kinds of music so he was
telling the other lady there he's like
oh my God look at this [__] YouTube
channel I discovered and it's called
y'all alternative yeah and so it's like
a guy doing like super country versions
of
um like 90s alternative song like pop
like Blink 182 and like stuff like that
and it's
annoying but also kind of hilarious at
the same time like it's hilarious for
like a second and then you're like all
right that's enough because I didn't
like blinking what I do and all that
stuff to start with it's like I really
don't need like a super country version
of that but I was like well that's
pretty funny that like they found a
niche and I love that they called it the
alternative to like crack me up but um
I'm trying to think of like movies that
I really really like the soundtracks of
I tend to like ones that have like a lot
of
like 80s right so I liked um like Donnie
Darko had a really good soundtrack that
had a lot of good songs in it that like
Echo the bunny bun and tears her fears
and stuff
um and I liked a lot of the ones from
like John Hughes
oh and I remember like the soundtrack
for valley girl being really good
because I think that like Psychedelic
Furs and stuff on it so that was like
really good Mr 88 had a good comment
about Shakespeare that he's he's about
subterfuge insubordination by
obfuscation
yeah that's what I'm saying you always
had to like talk and he clever word play
was like kind of his thing so he would
always kind of like talk around things
and you want to get his head cut off
well you know that's just what you did
like you kind of had to do that kind of
[__] and I kind of feel like writers
have been doing that for like a really
long time which is like look [__]
Oscar Wilde did that [__] too because he
was gay as [__] and you couldn't really
it was illegal but he went to prison for
it for a couple years actually I had to
break rocks for two years because he got
caught
but
um and he wrote a big [__] long epic
poem about it which was actually really
good called The Ballad of writing jail
I can't change so buddy
well why what do you mean Santa jail
he'll change that well that was kind of
just not what they were thinking though
they were just think we need to punish
these they were just thinking about
punishing because they were doing
something bad yeah no butt stuff it's
not allowed
right which is dumb because it's just
like what it doesn't what does that do
with that dude yeah it doesn't have
anything to do with you like why do you
care I'm thinking of the time I will
never understand that and like some
people still think that nowadays like
why are some people like worried about
what where others what other people do
are putting their dicks or vaginas or
whatever just consenting adults man
that's what I mean as long as nobody's
doing anything to somebody that doesn't
monitors like underage I'm like who
cares how these people are getting off
I'm like I don't care what you do that's
what they want to do man I don't care do
in your house that's like it doesn't
bother it doesn't Don't Force It on
anybody it doesn't affect me one [__]
bit not at all not at all
speaking of which I found another show
on Hulu because you know on um I guess
they're originally like on History
Channel but they had shows like they had
a uh the food that built America which
we just watched season three of which
was excellent and they also had like the
Machines That Built America and the men
that built America and all this like
they have like a whole series of these
and they're all like really really
interesting
well they have one
and I think it's just like a mini series
because it looks like there's only three
episodes unless it's still on and
they're putting episodes up slowly I'm
not really sure but this one is called
what's it called the set the sex booze
and Bets That Built America or it's
those three words but I don't remember
what order there so it's kind of all
about
and I thought it was kind of cool
because it's the same format as the
other show but they're going more into
like illegal trades so they're talking
about
um you know the guy that uh you know
brought cigarettes to like the wider
thing like started Marlboro and all that
um they're talking about
um you know prostitution they're talking
about like the founding of Las Vegas
they're talking about Moonshiners they
talked about I didn't realize
I was like oh today I learned that Jack
Daniel was a real guy
just like Little Debbie was a real girl
Mrs Fields is a real woman
um you know what I mean it's one of
those corporate mascots uh Chef Boyardee
was a real dude but yeah Jack Daniel was
a real guy he was like um well he worked
for a legal Distillery
and he also
um like did some bootlegging on the side
yeah they talk about how he got into the
into the hole who's business
he made for he had money he wanted to
have a business
he did he was working and it was in
another he was a preacher too wasn't he
or no no he worked for a preacher the
preacher owned a Distillery yeah and he
worked for that guy yeah he made friends
with this these two guys he's two black
dudes and one of them well they were
father and son they were Father and Son
the father was named nearest Green yeah
and he was a master distiller he was
like the best guy in the area so Jack
Daniel learned how to distill whiskey
from him yeah he was like his mentor
yeah and that was his that was his and
he had he was a was it was an ex-slave
the dad not the son but uh the dad was I
think and um yeah the dad was the dad
was yeah and uh they were good buddies
it's a good story
and then that dude ended up dying you
know and they show kind of a scene where
he was [__] up by they were at the
[__] well that was like his best friend
yeah it was like his best buddy man and
um but uh
he uh came up with uh
evidently in Africa they were distilling
in Africa and they would well no they
weren't still in Africa they had
water problems and they were filtering
water through charcoal
so he knew about cold charcoal filtering
which really improved whiskey yeah got
all the impurities yeah and then they
would filter the whiskey through
charcoal which Moonshiners weren't doing
nobody else was doing back then this is
like like right before like during and
after the Civil War right so
kind of a kind of an important
invention filtering the filtering and
then they would Age it in a barrel too
yeah they did all kinds of stuff well
they took them a while to figure out
except to get it right you know they
were for years they worked on it
they they specifically wanted which I
actually kind of admire they
specifically wanted to make it good they
wanted to make like a premium whiskey
they didn't just want to make like some
shitty moonshine like he had been doing
that
but he's like I want to make like some
really really good stuff so they tried
like a bunch of different recipes and
stuff they wanted to make like a more
premium brand yeah and the thing is is
that all the brewery brewing and
distilled distillation processes that
technology
was all European
so what you would come out with is a
European product so most of the
companies that were doing this back in
the days were trying to make American
versions of this stuff like you know
Anheuser-Busch yeah because that was
like another part of the show they were
talking about Anheuser but
Anheuser-Busch was trying to make a beer
that was American because
the other beers that were being made in
America were actually German you know
yeah it was all the Germans Germans that
came and brought they're all yeah and
that was mostly their customer base too
so uh
now it's funny you know what I mean uh
the main invention was the [__] he
was they were selling big old casts of
beer and with Anheuser-Busch written on
them
and then the bar owners would
sell it all and then refill that [__]
cast with cheap beer and sell it again
as Budweiser and it tasted like [__] so
they were like how the [__] do we stop
that yeah it's like that's dragging our
name through because they were one of
the first like National Brands right so
that wasn't really a thing solution was
is we're gonna make these bottles and
we're gonna bottle it in a bottle so
when you buy it you only buy it from a
bottle
and that was the first mass production
bottling so I mean say what you will
about Budweiser but it was and they were
the first ones to do refrigerated trunks
yeah refrigerator trucks because they
wanted to be able to sell their beer
west of the Mississippi because there
weren't any breweries out there you
couldn't get that somewhere it would
yeah
so yeah so they made like a lot of
Innovations like that company as shitty
as their beer is like compared to other
beers but you know what I mean
um well Budweiser is [__] piss water
today yeah but in the 1800s well yeah
that was like premium [__] yeah
because you know I've said this before
wine tasting is a bunch of [__]
[__] okay
back in the day they would do wine
tasting and you could taste yeah this is
a fine wine okay but if you were to go
down to Walmart today and get a box of
[__] Merlot
cheap box of [__] yeah just get the
wine in the Box it's like 10 bucks
and drinks it you know what I mean and
take that back in time
all right to the 17 or 1800s and have
him taste that they'd tell you that was
the best wine they'd ever had well it
probably was that was yeah and now that
that's the same with like food or
anything yeah because they didn't have
any standard for comparison back then
it's like well this is less shitty than
the other thing that we had they didn't
have anything really good I feel like
probably yeah all that wine taste and
[__] is [__]
um
you wine is good when you taste it you
like it that's what good wine is
all that wine tasting tradition came
from an era
when there were
wineries everywhere half of them [__]
substandard they're putting wide and
filthy bottles and this [__] [__]
goes bad in a couple [__] years you
know what I mean you tasted this like
sour like vinegar you know
um
there there it was most of it was just
how you know they just they would lack
of Sanitation
you know I feel like the thing about it
up to a certain point like um you know
up to a certain point price matters yeah
but that point is probably not as high
as most people think it is I think they
said if it goes over 80 bucks you've
wasted your money that's what I've heard
I mean I don't even know if I'd go that
far yeah I think it's probably like less
than that because honestly I bought some
wines for like 15 20 that were really
[__] good yeah I mean I'm no
connoisseur or anything but I'm just
saying some of that [__] status though
and Prestige right that well and a lot
of it is like packaging and like the way
that it's perceived but in the
marketplace like things like that so and
you know companies pay a lot of money to
be seen as a premium brand or something
like that so they can get a premium
price that doesn't necessarily mean that
it tastes a hundred dollars better than
the next one down in the market it
probably doesn't yeah and like we've
said that before it's like you know a
500 bottle of wine I'm like there I
can't imagine
I can't imagine anything that would make
me pay 500 but it can't be that good it
just can't I can't imagine what it would
taste like that would make me pay five
but even if I could afford it which I
can't but even if I could
I'm like how would that be
how would that be 10 times better than a
50 bottle there's no way it would
probably be dry there's no way it would
be dry and you probably wouldn't
appreciate it
I mean I remember hearing some [__]
where they would take these wide tasters
and uh blindfold them and give them
[__] random wines and they really
couldn't tell one ride from another I
mean like some of them I remember but
uh and you know now that I've seen some
of the [__] that Gordon Ramsay did to
people probably true they would [__]
blindfold [__] chefs and [__] give
them pork and ask them what that is and
they would go chicken
you know I see I always wondered they do
this every season on Hell's Kitchen if
you don't watch it because I've been
watching oh [__] I gotta watch the new
one actually because the new one's
probably up and I think it's the fun
it's the finale
but I might be too drunk to watch them
tonight I might have to watch tomorrow
but um every season they do and these
are like you know experienced chefs
right that he has on there and he always
does a blindfold taste test and they
almost always [__] it up like a a couple
of them I think on this last one like
one or two people did pretty good but
some of the people just got every single
one wrong and then and these are
supposed to be like people with really
good palettes and then I'm kind of
wondering I wonder how I would do
because it's like easy to sit at home
and be like how can you confuse you know
a mango for a pineapple because those
seasonings taste completely different
but it's like when you're not seeing
anything and you know maybe it wouldn't
right the experience isn't taste alone
you've seen it you know it is
so you have expectations right and then
the expectations are fulfilled so it
just goes to show like maybe how much
your eyes yeah your eyes has a lot to do
with it so I don't know what to expect
and then you taste it so you're confused
now because you didn't know what to
expect
I mean they gave that dude cheese and
they go what is that and he goes you
know you know he's he's eating his
butter or something [__] like that it'd
be something and you're like what you're
like what you know yeah he couldn't
identify it it was [__] cheese
now see I will admit that like some of
the stuff they give them it's like
probably be kind of hard because if you
can't see and they can't hear or
anything either and so if you give him
something I always kind of feel like if
you give them something that's like not
that doesn't have a super strong flavor
or a super strong texture like the for
example like he gave them like mushrooms
and I'm like okay that might be kind of
hard because mushrooms
particularly if they're uncooked which I
think they were they don't really taste
like much of anything yeah they have a
specific texture but other things have
that texture too like tofu or something
like that so it's like I can see getting
that wrong now some of the things that
they gave them I was like oh my God
there's no way they could [__] that up
because it's like it seems so
distinctive but you know something that
doesn't have that's very mild flavor
like potato or something like that I
could see you [__] that up because
that could be a lot of different things
but something that has a very
distinctive flavor but sometimes they
still [__] it up Oscar's in there saying
that Jack Daniels sucked basic Jack
Daniels I don't like it it's sour mash
whiskey I don't like it straight it's
good with Coke but I agree that Jameson
is better yeah Jameson's really good in
common
the thing is though I used to start my
morning with that back back in my
degenerate days the thing is those
there's now just a bunch of different
levels to Jack Daniels they got some
more premium version of it that are
really good
and they have some flavored stuff too
like they had one I think it sit like
it's like almost like a red hot cinnamon
or honey flavored or what is that they
do have a honey one I like the honey one
actually they have enough they have an
apple one too I think Jim Beam had a dab
apple one I thought yeah Jim Beam has
Apple [__] really good yeah I drink
that straight that's yeah that's nice
um so it's it's definitely artificially
flavored but it it doesn't matter it's
it's a drinking experience and you
didn't you didn't didn't cost you much
and it's quality it's good
I mean [__] there was some Brazilian
[__] that was low quality we still
drinking you know that shit's right gut
but you know so I have perspective
um pretty much all those American brands
are
safe to drink and the flavor is going to
be pretty good [__] mad dog 2020.
tastes good
cheap ass that's what I mean you can
even buy his like [__] from like
7-Eleven and that'll be all right yeah
it'll be drinkable it'll be drinkable
yeah Mad Dog tastes great which like I
said if you think about it like I said
watching these shows from like you know
when they were just when particularly
like when booze was like illegal or when
they didn't really know how to make it
or there wasn't really any good
sanitation it's like people are
basically drinking
just straight [__] alcohol that was
like nothing was filtered out it's like
they were using the same water that
people pooped in it's like you know what
I mean so people can piss and moan all
they want about this is better than that
but it's just kind of like anything like
our cheapest [__] nowadays would be like
100 times better than what they had
because it's like they're getting
[__] dysentery it's [__] just from
drinking that crap this tablet I have in
my hand
the richest man in the world
Howard Hughes back in the 60s didn't
have access to this that would have
blown his [__] mind okay Howard
Hughes one of the first men had air
conditioning in his house in one of his
houses and that blew people's [__]
minds all right just you take [__] for
granted
all right yeah I could go back to the
[__] 1300s and show this to the
[__] Pope in Rome all right and they
would have been killed well they either
that or just blow their [__] mind
okay which nothing or just tell them
that no I'm I'm God you know
I guess he is God holy [__] struck him
down just with my finger
[Laughter]
get him
[__]
oh [__] he is God
see how fast he reloaded
yeah you could get away without God
that's like pretty funny I would
seriously if I went back in a time
machine in the Middle East I'd get
burned for a witch like within seconds
I'm sure I don't think so
it's just
showed up especially first of all if you
were to go back to that era
for your age 50 they would not believe
you were 50.
well I have all mates I've already done
all my hair and you'd be clean and the
clothes they would they would think that
you were uh they would think you were
probably in your late 20s your 30s and
they would also think that you were some
kind of a noble
somebody with a lot of money
so they'd be scared of you they'd
probably be kneeling and [__] oh I could
probably work like a [__] you know I
could break that who are you married to
you know be calling him a lady and [__]
thanks and if you just get used to that
if they could understand what you were
saying you could probably say some [__]
tone just blow their mind you know oh
wow
I don't think that attack
I don't know when you look at the
witches when you look at witches it was
it was just some old woman old hag or
somebody who was somebody's enemy or you
know
I don't know if they'd know what I was
saying man yeah the way I talk
you could probably make yourself
understood you just you could tell me
you're a foreigner
he's from Barcelona yeah
um Mr 88 said David Lee Roth did a
Bluegrass version of jump not sure what
brought that on you know what that
reminded me of today another song that
they played for me at work was Dolly
Parton covering Stairway to Heaven have
you ever heard of that
no it was actually quite awesome yeah
I mean I was kind of expecting it to be
awesome because hey I like Dolly Parton
and I like Stairway to Heaven but um
yeah it was like really cool you should
like look it up on YouTube you'd
probably dig it yeah you probably dig it
I do too yeah she's awesome hot so yeah
she's she's also pretty hot yeah so yeah
that's the thing and it's I was just
kind of like I'm surprised I was like
how did I not know this existed because
I like Dolly Parton stuff but yeah she
did a cover of Stairway to Heaven and
it's actually quite cool
um Mr 80 it said by the way
um I've not been on many live streams
the past six months because my wife came
home uh on hospice in late August I was
her caregiver she passed away in
December oh sorry it's just 47. wow
today would have been our 27th
anniversary kind of unfortunate man man
that is like really sad I'm really sorry
well must have been cancer
I'm imagining yeah something like that
yeah we've had yeah he said don't want
to be a downer just wanted to let you
know yeah we've had if it was cancer
yeah good friends die of that we've had
just in the past couple years we had two
friends young young one was 34 and the
other one I think was 29. yeah pretty
girls yeah died of cancer also pretty
good that's like terrible
yeah leukemia he said it's like blood
bone marrow cancer like one of ours yeah
she died um
Kaylee died of uh uh stomach cancer yeah
yeah and it spread to her intestines and
all of it and Amber died of having
cancer all over her I thought she had
like yeah she had started uterine and
then it went everywhere everywhere yeah
poor girl young and they were pretty in
their 20s both of these girls were
really pretty
and like I said really young so like
it's socks man that's got to be like
some kind of [__] genetic thing like
dying that young like I said I had an
uncle that died of brain cancer and he
was only 32.
I think some of that uterine cancer can
actually start from viruses like HPV and
things like that some of them that's why
they're trying to that's why they're
doing the vaccination anyways but
smells like honey tastes like Brian my
wife just came back from the hospital
got appendicitis at 75. imagine that um
you know
um now that I think about it I'm pretty
sure I still have my appendix because a
lot of people get them removed right
yeah but you have to have an operation
for that well yeah I know that but you
would know if you had an operation for
that right well unless I was a kid no I
feel like I knew some people that had it
like done I saw my tonsils as well I had
mine removed I know most people had them
I don't think it does anything though
I think it was some [__] they just
tried to sell people
I don't know but like I said I still got
mine your insurance covered it they just
wanted that money
take his tonsils out he won't get his
stick well they're in there for a reason
come on
well see that's what I always kind of
figured I was like well nature put that
there I mean or not well I'm not saying
that it's like everything we have is for
a reason because we have a lot of like
leftover [__] that doesn't do anything
because you know we're just a collection
of like I was leftover [__] I was
circumcised at Birth
well that's what they did well that's
what they did well I don't know I don't
know about nowadays yeah but Pookie's
running away she's like circumcision bye
but oh look at all that she don't want
to talk about it she doesn't know what
that is but um yeah I actually didn't
realize until like a few years ago that
yeah they I I'm I don't know if they ask
you but I thought they just like default
yeah they did back in those days which
is weird like you think that like they'd
give you the option they just did it
automatically because I'm not a fan I
don't I don't really think they should
see the explanation that I got
is that
is that in that air in that era uh the
doctors were were uh were Jewish or they
came or they were educated by Jewish
professors and that they just did that
automatically as it was health and it
also religion because
um you know the the Covenant is keeping
up the Covenant with uh with God and
Jews and Christians were worship the
same God so you just did it
automatically
well I always heard yeah that but I
always heard like oh it was cleaner and
then yeah
um there was a whole thing then so many
people had it done that parents were
worried that their kids would get made
fun of if they didn't get it done
because they'd look different than other
kids at gym or whatever and so it's like
oh well we better do it because we don't
want our son to get made fun of so then
it became like a feedback loop I don't
know I don't have any children so so I
don't know what the State of Affairs is
nowadays but I just thought that was
like always a weird
thing to do well because I feel like you
know remember in the 80s when there was
kind of like a fad for if you had a baby
girl oh let's Pierce her ears while
she's still a baby I'm like why the [__]
would you do that and it's like that's
kind of like a more minor version
of circumstance like why would you just
like oh we had a baby let's cut Parts
off of it that's like why would you do
that it's like if they want to cut parts
off later on okay fine but it's like
they can't make that decision it doesn't
make any difference though you're not
being born I mean it doesn't but being
born you know that way I didn't know any
different than of course you know I have
sex I enjoy it right it doesn't yeah you
don't know any different but I'm just
saying it just seems like a weird thing
to do like I just feel like if I'd ever
had a kid like that was a little boy I'd
be like yeah I would I don't know I just
think I'd rather not I'm like let's just
not cut into the kid okay just as little
as possible I think it was I think it
was just strange I think it had to do
with with the original Covenant well I
know it did I know that's where it came
from but I'm just saying that they
assumed or they believed that because it
was in the in in the Covenant that and
it maybe would avoid some infections by
doing that that it was God's wisdom so
yeah that's what you do right but that's
just you know yeah but like I said
coming from coming from somebody who was
not raised religiously and religion
doesn't make a lot of sense to me so I'm
just kind of like well from a practical
standpoint it's like I don't really want
to have a baby and then just have them
like cut pieces off here's the trip
though
imaginary okay God in his wisdom tells
you to remove your foreskin that way to
avoid infections and to prove your
loyalty okay
but for some reason just doesn't have
you born without the force kids well see
that was what always bothered me it's
like well if he didn't want you to have
it why do you have it
it's outside of protection that's what
I'm saying this [__] doesn't make any
sense you're gonna lose some sensitivity
I'm like the I'm like the [__] is there
like I said not advancing for being a
one minute Wonder
I mean not everything on your body has a
purpose okay we do have like vestigial
like organs and things like that because
like I said we're kind of a clutch
together uh you know conglomeration of
like our past ancestry going back to the
Animal Kingdom and Beyond so it's like
we have a bunch of [__] left over that
doesn't do [__] I get that but I'm just
kind of like
I I'm a big advocate of like let's just
leave it there unless if something goes
wrong with it then we'll deal with it
down the line but it's like let's not
just have her pop right out you know
have him pop right out the womb and
start like chopping pieces off it just
seems a little bizarre to me I'm just
saying
I don't know I'm not you know no shade
if like you you want to do that I'm just
saying that because that's your decision
I suppose but
I don't know it just seems weird to me
because like I said I wasn't raised
religious and it's like it doesn't make
any sense to me
yeah Mr 88 said about his wife she was a
superstar she's getting permanent
memorials at the middle school she
taught at the University she got her
doctorate at and the hospital she worked
at holy [__] that's awesome I mean you
know
I feel really bad about but you know
that is awesome that it's like she's
gonna be remembered like that
so how long has the show been going on
uh wow two hours and 50 minutes I had
that three I can't believe I held out
for this long well once I started
drinking I felt better
yeah yeah what time is it uh 10 16. okay
I mean I feel okay I'm just really tired
yeah you know what I mean I'm just
really tired because I woke up really
early I for some reason I wake up
technically I have to leave to get to
work on time about
quarter to seven
you know just to be on the safe side
um but for some reason I always wake up
at like 4 30.
because I'm like oh well if I get up
early then I'll have time to like get
ready and like do some work and [__]
like before
leaving before I leave
and I'll have plenty of time so I can
just like I don't have to rush because I
hate having to rush you know what I mean
so I always like wake up at [__] 4 30
so I don't know so at least tomorrow I
can [__] sleep in but I'm sure I
probably won't
I'm sure I'll probably wake up at
[__] six or seven a.m just like
always and be like doink
which sucks all right let's go ahead and
shut it down Jeff yeah shut it down yeah
go ahead shut it down I'm gonna I'm
gonna go
have some little Debbies yeah and watch
the rest of that show I guess okay well
I mean I'll probably like put that show
and then fall asleep in like 10 minutes
because I'm probably like gonna get
really tired
uh yeah Oscar said shut this bee down
yeah I'm actually really glad that we
went this long because I was having a
good time but you know what I mean
all right so we will be back on we'll do
a show on Sunday because like I said we
were supposed to do a movie review about
Gattaca because we watched it but we
haven't done the review yet so we should
do that on Sunday
and then we'll get to these ones too
like and it might not be Tuesday but it
might be like the following week you
know what I mean
but we'll get to them uh as soon as
possible so thank you very much Louie if
you're still here for sending them to us
right yeah I'm gonna get on
yeah we'll watch them yeah we'll watch
it but we got to do Gattaca first yes
we've already like uh watched that and I
already got notes for that and
everything like that so we'll probably
do it on Sunday so we'll see you guys
again on Sunday thank you everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats
remember to like and share and all of
that other and comment too because
that's uh that also helps as well uh so
yeah we will see you guys again on
Sunday good night